don't identity dented that was some epic
music to get us ready for what we expect
to be one of the most epic matches of
the 2017 speed chess championship right
here alongside me hosting his first ever
speed chess match is the one and only
the chess prof. found our Grand Master
Eric Hanson you ready I'm totally ready
Danny I'm always excited for my first
time you know what you have to be you
always have to be and can I say that you
look as professional as we've ever seen
you I'm not sure who helped you get
dressed here today but we really do
appreciate the black tie it looks looks
good well my partner is a Danny wrench I
have to put in some effort yeah well the
the people that are really going to be
putting in effort here today are our
players Magnus Carlsen and Qadir Gucci a
Knopf but first let's remind everybody
what they're about to tune in for this
is the 2017 speed chess championship all
of these faces have already played
besides Magnus Carlsen and Gucci enough
on the line here well before we get to
what's on the line the format everybody
as a reminder we have blitz followed by
bullet with chess960 sprinkled in
between the the entire format of the
speech Chess Championship can be read
about as speech as championship calm but
here's a quick preview we have round 1
this is the last round of round 1 we
will then be whittled down to 8 players
and then we have the semifinals and the
finals taking place in November and
December today of course we have Magnus
Carlsen and Qadir goo Sienna off with
only $1,000 on the line but really the
biggest prize is moving on to the second
round where everything gets more intense
and the prize is significantly increased
as we go and remind everybody this is
the bracket these are the people that
have already won their matches and as
you can see only one spot and that upper
left has yet to be filled and that is by
the world champion Magnus Carlsen so on
that note reminding everybody what
they're in for Erik what do you expect
that we are in for here on the board we
know that the world champion is
obviously a heavy favorite pretty much
against anybody he goes up against but
what do you see happening between these
two players as far as their styles and
and what do you think is gonna happen in
the online blitz format well based on
the Styles I think did
as to start off really well Magnus in
the past has beaten everyone except for
naka in Bullitt very badly and he
generally finishes very strong I'm
looking at the chest 960 and the
preliminary blitz portions as as a
moment or a session for goose enough to
strike because otherwise I don't think
even let Magnus get into his rhythm
he's just so strong down the stretch and
he is a heavy favorite I'm looking for
my first upset I'm not sure if it's
going to be today Danny but it's gonna
have to be a good start that's for sure
but you're right and on that note we
haven't actually ever seen an upset yet
of course it's a little misleading as
everyone knows the 89 matchup right
between Wesley and Ani SH was very very
close went to overtime but even even in
a matchup that close and then we had the
Nepal Miyoshi and Levon Aronian match
were again the favorite the 7 seed won
so though it's a slightly misleading
stat you're right we have never yet seen
an upset in this format I wonder if
that's a little bit like the NBA with
when in a seven-game series with so many
blitz games being played Eric you just
rarely ever see the underdog be able to
hold their own for the entire match
right we know Magnus be taking on
Petrosyan last year in the first round
by a score of 21 to 4
do you think it'll be that lopsided
today or do you think a deer has a
chance if he gets off to that good start
you're speaking of I've played good deer
I lost him in the world us championship
I think he's a very good looks player
but yeah he's gonna have to start a
start well early Petrosyan scored two
points in the first portion against
Magnus so 62 not that would it not not
that bad I got a much worse down down
the stretch so I think I'll be a bit
better than that but you really will
have to start off early it's gonna be so
frustrating dealing with Magnus well and
on that note the games are about to
start I'm making sure that everything is
set but it looks like the players are
here we see Magnus sitting down sipping
on maybe some tea Kadir is has has shut
himself in away from his children today
which is
he said he's got two kids in the house
with him so they're they've they've been
tucked into bed he's got himself a
private room and apparently a cough but
these new guys are getting set to play
everybody the games will be starting in
less than 30 seconds Eric I expect
nothing but the best today from you the
leader of the chess bras I expect
commentary that blows our minds and I'm
just gonna sit back relax and try not to
mess things up too badly I think we're
ready to do this here we go I hope so
I've the match the match has begun and
we have efore played well yeah on move
one go ahead
one thing about casino busy is a very
narrow repertoire the good part about
that and blitz is you can play it
quickly get up on time the bad part is
it's gonna be hard to make adjustments
okay so I your this is this is what's
his a repertoire over the board are we
seeing something that we would normally
see here with e4 being his weapon of
choice yes yes he played e4 against me
he mainly plays e4 and as black he also
chooses just a few systems well as you
talk about good ears chest strengths and
his style remind everybody a little bit
about our Challenger since so many
people know so much about Magnus Carlsen
Agadir is 31 years old he is currently
ranked number four to number 100 114 in
the world
originally from Moscow and he didn't
have a life path to become a chess
player Erik in fact he has several
sisters and all of them are doctors he
is the literal black sheep of the family
becoming a chess player his dad is an
anesthesiologist so little little fun
facts a little bit of research things
people can know about Kadir in 2015 he
played he actually found out he became a
father right before he played a chess
game have you ever been in those shoes
Erik I'm happy in the way that I was
raised as an only child which means I
can get away with chess a little but I'm
not being compared to very much no I
meant have you ever found out you were a
dad right before you played a chess game
not yet okay all right well what do we
have here on the board we've got we've
got appearance and a classical approach
from white just developing the pieces
with an early e5 what's the approach
here for white it's interesting Magnus
has been playing this a lot lately very
flexible I don't have you noticed that
he's also smiling and
laughing a little bit yes clearly quite
relaxed but white he's not playing
anything critical is just that I guess
it's a fairly symmetrical structure with
slight leading developments for white
he's gonna try to get up I mean I don't
see much here but got a little bit of a
pull in the end game with that lead lead
in development I'm not exactly sure how
he's going to achieve that he's going to
have to use gained some space or do
something pretty quickly because I don't
see I don't see what the idea is to be
honest
well the switching over to our analysis
analysis mode here we have what position
do we have on the board the Queen's have
come off yeah we got Bishop g4 is the
last move Queen's off rook ft-1 Bishop
g4 Magnus completing development and
what can I say this looks completely
equal and Magnus already has a minute so
on but the only open file being the D
file though and the battle probably
gonna become about who's able to sort of
grab control over these critical squares
d5 and d4 who do you think has the
better chance there with this move
Bishop g4 Magnus can eliminate the
knight on f3 and and pop a pony into d4
is this the idea yeah that might be the
idea the it's as you say both both
players have the same thing that the
Knights on c6 and c3 wanted the off
those squares
you don't want United from the pawn you
want to have your pawn on c3 covering
that d4 square but the issue is for an
e5 so which player can rearrange first
and I think right here good dear did
King f1 I was expecting that that's a
fair move otherwise I think he was
planning to move that night away and
trade off LightSquared bishop and say
hey the bishop on g7 is not so good
locked behind its own pawn on e5 white
can play around that and so Magnus goes
for that idea and as you said white
would like to kind of do the same with
the knight on c3 but moving it at least
previously would have had problems with
the e4 pawn now that Magnus has the
knight on d4 we have both C 2 and F 3
sort of being forked here it feels like
black is is getting a slightly better
pool as they head into the endgame is
this is this a vintage Magnus approach
here
he's playing the best moves in the
position they're not that hard to find
which means I'm not too thrilled with
Hussein I was approached this game but
yeah I if you can keep that head on d4 I
definitely think this is easier to play
for block and I can leverage that into a
nice solid time advantage and healthy
pressure yeah speaking of time advantage
you make a great point that's really
probably the one advantage you can
clearly see right now is that black is
up about a minute and a half on time so
let's analyze if white plays a move like
rook to see one or even rook to d2 okay
he actually did play Brooke c1 is is
Magnus gonna take on f3 and double the
pawns or is he gonna keep the knight on
d4 I think he's gonna keep an eye on d4
hoping that at some point white takes on
d4 and then the pawn structure becomes
imbalanced you can't take on f3 but
those double bonds aren't so easy to
access for 4 blocks okay and that looks
like you're right right now he's sitting
tidy plays a six sort of prophylaxis
against an idea of Knight to b5 perhaps
what's the what's the plan then if
you're gonna keep the knight on d4
obviously this is the only open file on
the board everybody and right now it
doesn't seem super critical but if black
is able to double Brooks on the D file
and then look to make some sort of
tactics happen whoever gets access into
the other side's cam via that open file
is probably gonna be the only one with
winning chances as we transition but but
how would you build how would you build
strength in this position if you were
black okay well your comes Knight to d5
a six I was trying to stop Knight b5 in
some positions black wants to double on
the D file without something there so I
didn't go stopping Knight d5 but now now
things are a bit critical here yeah take
I mean block can take on d5 take on f3
and just double on the D found play
against that pawn but okay this is still
relatively balanced what can always
strengthen that d5 pawn to c4 and it's
gonna take some more maneuvering for
blocks to get something here and
possibly if white is getting under time
pressure and desperate maybe he can even
take on d4 and if we have enough
opposite colored bishop ending probably
decent drawing chances for both sides
there mm-hmm okay so
Magnus plays rook d7 as we said he's
probably gonna double rooks on the deef
and if that happens you have to look out
for threats on f3 because at that point
taking on f3 may become a real threat if
the d5 pawn is falling so so kisi enough
says he's tired of getting around and
play rook e1 and W works on just say
this is opposite bishops and that's
quite cool Ron I think rook e1 might be
the thing the one thing you have to
watch out for is this d3 shot d3 at some
moment maybe not here but you know then
if I can get rid of that bond strength
as bishop and trade one for one you'll
be happy but quite simple by on Ricky -
Roxy g1 and just trade pieces and all
you know four pawns on Queen side three
pawns are the king side opposite bishops
this is super equal then should be
pretty straightforward yeah the one
thing you look at is time of course and
you wonder as easy as the position
should be to play for White will time
pressure play a factor I'm one of the
reasons Eric says that everybody for our
more beginner viewers just opposite
colored bishops have a dynamic where
they just can't attack each other they
can't challenge each other which makes
them sort of sort of just bystanders to
the others plan and you get situations
like this where White has completely
blockaded on the light squares black has
completely blockaded on the dark squares
and and that's why he and I both kind of
have a tone expecting this to just be
kind of a pretty easy to draw you know
time pressure not a side so Magnus here
wants to play rugby six wants to provoke
b3 and we consume more darks first right
he pretty much considers this a free
roll he's not gonna lose this game he's
up on time and I think he's gonna do
what he does best prolong the game and
use his famous stamina and endurance to
to hurt his opponents that deep into the
game yeah and as they say it is a game
right even if the science aspect is is
accurate and with you and I saying that
this should be a draw with best play
we're not all supercomputers and that's
how Magnus Carlsen wins a lot of games
but just outlasting and making less
mistakes in his opponent's so here is
he's he's managed to separate the pollen
so we have our first sort of even though
it's not very much our first sort of
imbalance in the position and look at
this move c5 take advantage of the pin
and maybe he has b5 coming on the next
move yeah I think now I play a four stop
be fiver to trade off my isolate upon
didn't shift my work to the the beef
I'll play c4 at some point
and okay they've done that let's see I'm
looking for tricks here but it does it
doesn't feel like what's done enough you
note one of those cases White's not
playing for any sort of edge but has he
really made it any mistakes to put
himself in hot water and I don't I don't
think so yet but again Black has managed
to makes you three a bit of a weakness
and achieve the desirable structure you
know pawns on the light squares like
that in that good dark spurt Bishop
right so expand on that for our lower
rated and um and not lower rate even me
okay Hugh why why is putting the pawns
on the light squares an advantage for
black why is that part of the goal well
for one thing you cover both squares on
the board you have a good darks for
Bishop now you have a lot square
presence but if your pawns are you know
in front of your own the same colors or
Bishop that might be hard might just be
blocking your own Bishop and and hard to
maneuver around it so it definitely
complements the bishop to have the pawns
on the other squares so it can renew you
know just go right by right ok so with
Kadir getting enough pressure on the b5
pawn it seems like it's gonna be hard to
Magnus to do any kind of rima new ring
to hit c3 without that beep on right now
I want to run the King to d6 but the
issue I'm running into now is Bishop e2
Bishop takes c4 might be a threat which
is why I think Magnus is taking the
approach there should be five and
rewriting putting on c7 yep so this
tactic doesn't work as well but d6 is
yeah d6 there's d6 here and you need to
go Bishop d8 and try to be real stubborn
or you let everything get traded off and
this is where we're gonna know if it's
gonna be an immediate draw or not right
right if you line like this happens
sorry go ahead
no I'm saying b5 Falls seed fork goes
with it yep just showing that tactic on
our analysis board for the fans day idea
here everybody's at the B pawn is pinned
and this would actually be losing for
Magnus as he loses material so Kadir
throwing this renegade d6 pawn at him as
Eric said and Magnus has to make a
choice do I want to win badly enough to
play bishop d8 and keep this tactic off
the board and then black would have to
find a way to work around and get this
pawn or does Magnus not like that idea
and decide to just yeah it looks like
he's decided it's not worth the risk and
he's gonna like a dear get get away with
with a big simplification
here mm-hmm okay so the b-pawn is gonna
be traded for the c-pawn likely
everybody as Kadir I don't see any
reason why he can't talk on b5 yeah he
does yeah there was a rook takes b5 rook
be to c6 and there would be some nice
tactics for block okay show that show
that there for the fan that's nice so if
white had tried to take care of Magnus
would have switched and kept an
initiative against the white king so but
as is it looks like well well the time
is concerning Danny 15 seconds he's just
putting himself at risk here yeah I mean
the white is up upon its it's Magnus may
be decided to play on a bit more due to
this time management yeah and let's
remind everybody what the time controls
are as we as we switch over to the
scoreboard some some beginner users
wonder how the how the clock gets time
added back to it they are playing with a
two second increment so even with Kadir
being lower on time he will be gaining
two seconds to move as long as he can
keep it up but nobody wants to be living
off the increment when they're playing
against the world champion so I agree
you're a dear blows this it'll it'll
likely be time to blame negatives
decline the draw I see that here and
what I see is at some point black blocks
making darts for weaknesses I might even
want to move my king from g7 all the way
to g3 that's a dream right I can
actually see it happening I Ghaderi here
is losing the threat he is losing the
throw this is two pawns each but the
pawns are are both isolated the King is
weak and you're just down a minute and
the rooks are going to both be on the
second rank this is getting yeah you can
lose at any moment if he if Magnus is
trying to think how he wants to gamble
with this obviously white is is all in
on the C pawn here and in black if I
could just stop the C pawn the two pawns
will definitely win the day but how do
you get in front of the C pawn here you
yeah you have to do what he's doing
because there yeah there's no other way
but here comes rook b6 right yeah and
now does black have enough time to get
the other rook back to help looks like
he does he can come to the e of the D
file now and meet c7 with rookie 7 yeah
and that's that's exactly what Magnus is
doing rookie 7 and now
think he's gonna push the pawns or put
the King on g5 and then start pushing
but yeah this you know what has it his
king can go all the way to b7 daddy so
we might see a position with a rook
against too advanced connected passed
pawns because that that King goes to b7
black can bail out take on c7 both rooks
and white will have a look and a king
very far away so rhymes animals did the
right thing here I think Magnus didn't
play that broccoli maybe he could have
well it's hard to say actually maybe
instead of rush out upon yeah yeah
instead of rushing the G pawn maybe try
to do something we're both King and
pawns come forward everybody as Eric was
highlighting Magnus well the king is cut
off here and Magnus is still up on time
right see you can come up with something
Rick c4 okay that's good you're doing
you should just yeah he needs to he
needs to the reason why Eric is pushing
for this everyone is if the rooks are
traded white can finally get the King
back over and it looks like a deer does
play Brooke c4 on the second time around
you don't want to be in a rook ending
where your king is way too far away from
the other pawn so mm-hmm well you can
just easily lose this just it's not
losing it's not losing a position but at
all and now Rick F says okay no he's
kicking against Jeb first but now he's
gonna he's gonna he's got look at that
king is now now the king is stuck on the
a file and yeah locks come bring his
king and I think King g7 king of six
yeah looks like a classic classic Magnus
for sure maybe this way he's boxed them
in here and yep and we seem to have lost
Kadir on camera for the moment I'm sure
he'll be right back awesome on camera
but the other position the position is
also one so we've lost Kadir in more
ways than one and we the main so it to
go back here to what we've seen Eric the
this is seems to be totally vintage mad
because mate but actually you can't stop
it rook b3 I check I check on beef I'll
trade all the rooks off and I think it's
a winning king and punning game I think
you see enough goes down in the first
game and what we have is yeah we have
what we have is what we see a lot of
Magnus Carlsen out playing people in
equal positions and going on to win the
game I'm
I'm gonna attempt here to get Agadir
back right now and see if I can I just
need to I noticed I only half of myself
only half of your showing right now I'm
gonna just you know just that there's
not much you can do actually this is
good let's look at here come back and
we'll just let it be
oh that's cuz good dear yeah yeah
because you wanna call I thought you
just wanna only half of me no I well I
want the whole thing I want all America
you can scoot over if you want a little
bit to your right for now but get your
should be back momentarily the I'm not
sure I'm not sure why we lost his camera
but I'm gonna I'm gonna attempt to get
him on right now um but Danny when I was
looking at how good he was gonna do well
he had to he has to play quick yeah and
especially when he doesn't have a lot of
openings he's he's a natural players a
good blitz player he's very fast good
ball player but really a bit of an
unforced error there let's see let's see
if he just I mean this is his first time
playing
he didn't play last two in the
blood-spot oh this is his first time
playing this format you could just be
warming up but losing with white like
that without putting any pressure at
along Magnus is not not a good start
back gideros back and we have all of
Eric Hanson back as well so that's nice
well with the with the first game going
to Magnus and him winning is black
unfortunately that's just difficult to
be in that spot as the as the Challenger
right because this is as you said Eric
this is kind of you know the the task
you're up against Magnus he's not gonna
try to to blow you off the board he's
just gonna grind you down and if you're
not fast enough you'll be consistently
the one who's under time pressure first
and even though we were predicting that
game to be kind of an okay draw for
white as we said time pressure played a
factor and eventually goo st. up wasn't
able to hold yeah I mean an especially
an end game like that where you're a
little bit worse but you're playing
maybe the best and game player in the
world especially when it comes to
building pressure you're gonna pull
yourself you're gonna be losing a lot of
positions that may not be lost but I
mean you just can't go toe to toe with
Magnus with less time than him in a
position said he's simply better better
at so we'll see he's doing a much better
job this game Danny first one - played
edge for ambitious I like it but that
that also gives a gives a block some
squares and some weaknesses to target as
well so he's adjusting better this game
is he's up a few seconds here and
seemingly okay out of the opening I see
one danger here Danny if black castles
King said I actually see Magnus pushing
those kingside bombs and just just 24
yeah watching an attack on the Kings
side not quite a traditional Yugoslav
attack but anything you can do to pry
open blacks King I agree that might be
might be where we're headed so with both
players back we take a look at how they
how they look looks like Magnus's Magnus
has gone to the snacks Eric he's chewing
on something good yeah I'm looking at
this again and I ok he's offering me
seven as a pawn which yeah I might take
that the more I look at it the more I
like White's position here
yeah good dear actually just sort of
shrugged and shuffled and put his hand
to his face and I think he agreed that
either that was just an accident or or
didn't like the trade of the e4 the
b-pawn after that last game Danny Magnus
is now
back over 3000 blitz right and it's it's
nice to be over 3,000 that's a cool
thing
oh I'm definitely jealous have you ever
have you ever crossed the 3,000 barrier
the only relation I have to 3,000 Danny
is I helped you car go get 3000 on the
regular business a regular basis right
yeah you're very you're very uh you're
generous I mean I'm an assist man I'm a
Steve Nash yep that's right but Magnus
as I said continues that you want
something I can't tell if it's Cheetos
I'm seeing a little orange dust around
his lips or if he's uh or if he's got
some carrots but either way Magnus has
gone to snack town that deers a little
frustrated and I mean this is a house
house you gonna deal with that stuff
this is like game over Danny this is
this is very close to me like Rick fate
runs at the bishop you seven Bishop e6
runs interpret 67 your queen is out of
play here and no I I mean he played
quickly quicker here yeah Danny but I'm
not sure I almost called you yesterday I
doubt you did a lot of World Cup
coverage with yeah it's not a bad thing
but this is this is looking I don't know
route 67 the tactics are all in White's
favor yep ya know Brooke takes b7 and by
the way you can call me yessir anytime
and that works in our relationship I
told my wife that I said you could call
me yessir anytime and she thought it was
weird but I think you rook d7 now yeah
right yeah rook d7 and in white white is
bringing the heat here um he's just
gonna gobble d6 likely okay you could
also trade on f8 if he decides
simplifying leaves him with an edge
maybe Bishop takes a fake Queen takes d7
trade everything and then grab an open
file or go after the d4 pawn something
like Queenie for after King takes g7
might be good yeah I think I mean rook
66 here already maybe Brooke 66 Ricky
and I wanna play Bishop f6
but and use that D pawn but yeah he has
to make some decisions he too is hanging
and maybe you want to keep that bomb
right but okay he's managed I like what
he's done I thought I was really really
bad he's played some important news like
we need for example to stop White's
attack with tactics so he's still got
chances here this yeah this is he's a
game this is great
Kadir good year defended that position
well given that we were looking at at
death be certain on f7 and the seventh
rank so here he goes for the line you
said and I expected will see either
Bishop f6 or Bishop g5 the the d5 pawn
has passed everybody and that's that's
kind of the key here for Magnus that he
managed to yeah so Bishop f8 is probably
met by rook c6 and then white defense
see - so like Liga dear is gonna have to
allow the Bishop trades and either take
on its ec2 right away or take f6 first
if yeah you wanna you don't want to give
white that diagonal because I mean he's
done it but I'm worried that at some
point white plays rook c6 if you can
ever get that Bishop and maintaining on
the dying yeah you know Queen f6 you you
know the Queen and Bishop on that
diagonal not so easy to accomplish still
so he went for that approach I said he
wouldn't and Magnus defended see - but
now gatir plays rook c8 I think he wants
to take on c6 and take on c2 right and
there's almost no way to stop that so
two's a weak bond that I think you just
have to give up his way and you want to
get the best version possible and maybe
Magnus transitions into an idea you were
talking about something like even Queen
f4 here just kind of give up the c6 pawn
for the d4 pawn with the idea that you
know he might get this might get this
idea of a mating that eventually on the
dark squares I wonder how Magnus will
will handle this threat of rook to c8
there's also risky idea plan would be
one here saying that if black takes on
c6 that'll be in advance postponed and
and that's worth giving up some material
for I'm not sure if that's that's not
yet but he's gone for for g3 I like this
approach
solid solid freeze the king so you're
not worried about back rank checks the
King now has g2 a safety square to hide
because if you take on c6 and you take
on C - okay no actually he's
I missed the tactic there but you see
for Danny we missed that move ooh
that's on facade be nice that is a nice
nice move that is a magnet of everybody
if black doesn't on passant Magnus has
just created an epic poem structure very
very solid and it'll actually lead to
two passers and if Kadir on poisson s'
well now he's able to capture back with
the bishop and suddenly threats of Queen
f6 are on the board that's an image what
that is a game-changer thank you already
drew yeah classic Magnus and snacks and
software soft drinks to go with it the I
am being reminded by my staff that we
have a we have a contest going on
obviously everyone can see Magnus has
gone back to kind of the clean the
clean-cut look here with his hair
not quite the nice fro that you got
going on Erik but he's got a clean-cut
look but he did have this crazy look so
we actually are doing a Photoshop
contest anyone can add crazy hair on to
me or Eric during the show or to any
picture or send in pictures of your own
crazy hair either way best
best photo gets a one-year Diamond
membership use the hashtag speed speech
s on Twitter use the hashtag and and we
will we will be following all of your
tweets throughout the entire show so
that's a quick quick reminder that we
have some fun stuff going on on social
media Eric let's go back to the to the
players and their and their analysis
yeah well I think he's just gonna take
on g7 here double rooks on the sea fowl
he's also got Queen f6 check whenever he
wants he's done it just double works on
the C file play d6 and also he's got
some threats on the seventh rank here he
plays rook d7 trans Queen f7
he's got the initiative at g3 move is
nice as well makes the King a bit more
secure but yeah Magnus is up a full pawn
here with the initiative that c4 move
was everything good dear played a5 maybe
he should have gone pawn hunting at that
exact moment but that's so easy to miss
c4
yeah c4 was a as you said a game-changer
and the transition has now been been
pretty clear that White has the best of
it and also the time is no longer
Magnus down on time they're getting
closer to equal
Queeny six doesn't work because you can
play these trade Queens play d7 just
pushed up on down the board here here
he's gonna do it anyways because he has
a meeting idea with rook rook BD a rook
c8 there's Queen's xd7 so rook see it's
not possible here but Magnus can play
Queen d6 or Queen
maybe Queen d6 here yeah yeah and keep
that keep that going
there's also Queen c6 and I'd like to
play rook c8 everybody but as arrow
point out the reminder the queen is on
this square defending it on the diagonal
so okay Queenie seven has other
intentions in mind what's the plan here
is he gonna is he gonna back up the
Queen but yet you can't go too far in
between if you go to c5 then the d7 pawn
Falls no you have no squares here this
is why I might have been attracted to
Queen c7 because of this exact move
order now blacks ready to play King of
seven kingi seven and when that pawn
right so it's gonna be hard to stop
maybe Brooke a7 here Danny and then
okay's gone for this one yeah we're
gonna see king of seven and then we do
expect Magnus will probably lose the d7
pawn for the a5 pawn and he'll still be
up upon in this rook ending the question
is will it be enough to win and black
structure isn't great right and talking
about Magnus here so this is this is
this is pretty pretty tough right over
park you might be able to play Brooke a7
and rook you seven and he's done that I
think he's gonna go really which is have
enough forces black to suppose we're
gonna have six which is not ideal pretty
passive defensive like we're probably
gonna see maybe f4 to follow and the
white king starts to get involved at
four thousand five there's gonna be
concrete because then then black like
I'm simplifying so so Magnus plays the
slower King G - yeah might be f3 and g4
here to make some weaknesses right f3
and g4 and and push that point up to up
to g5 or or take on h5 and gang up on
that pawn also you have the idea that
three King f2 King III and just
protecting my pawns and keeping black
passive and waiting for mistakes
the position yeah knowing it looks like
Kadir has gone into the think tank here
probably trying to think about how to
stop that plan he'd like to maybe run
his King up to d4
that might prevent king of to King III
so how does Magnus deal with a move like
king d5 and king d for coming
well I can put my king to e2 and I can
always check you I can always get you
from behind right and 1970 so there's no
long-term way of doing so I'm gonna say
that this time game difficult loss is
very very close to lost right now
because of the bad positioning of blocks
pawns and pieces here King III that rook
is passive I think he can now play g4
effortlessly no risk at all and we're
gonna see a couple moves maybe g5 put
the rook on f6 or your is is g5 and
bringing the rook to h6 an idea to maybe
get h5 I guess yes that also might yeah
yeah it just there's nothing you can do
is block this is this is like you know
Magus is enjoying everything and games
without risk right he's also like these
games are going long so he's sort of not
giving his opponent like you know you
sort of want to lose this game as black
and when you're good saint-aubin and get
a chance it's white but you got to
suffer the whole way through and lose
time in this portion and I think I think
as I said Magnus has done really well in
bullet besides but that's not all
that's something we've seen and not
necessarily been been surprised about
but after watching Magnus Carlsen win
the first speeches championship last
year where he he king of three kings
before he can get his king and involved
here yeah even even this slow slow and
patient idea make a waiting move with
the rock Kings in opposition yeah yeah
he's gonna put the king of d5 I think
we're cage one and then king d5 move
move the rook one more time yep
but I thought you could have brought his
king in another way but this way still
works
this is nice King d5 uh-huh and now is
king on f5 rook f1 check you're just
gonna give up the H pawn for the D pawn
yeah but the Box King is gonna be
outside now rook it oh this is this is
nice then it doesn't even need to right
he'll use the H pawn old old-school
decoy method and this is nice it this is
I mean we're just watching we're just
watching me
perfect technique right mm-hmm perfect
perfect rook endgame technique and he
goes on to beautiful again we got a we
got a whole lot of people and their
cousins playing playing guess the move
on chess calm if you log into chess calm
you can actually guess along with the
players so I it happened so fast there
there's so many people in the chat I
couldn't list all of your names but
thanks to everybody who's playing guess
the move so there we have it Eric we
have a 200 lead right now for Magnus and
as you said he's enjoying everything
everything that is his style and unlike
sometimes with other underdogs you don't
really see it getting easier for Agadir
as this time control gets faster right I
don't know I think Magnus is a big
favorite in bullit especially when he's
like playing like a Anaconda here by the
time it reaches the the bullet portion
Kadir might be a corpse if this
continues yeah well last year remember
he beat Tigran Petrosian in his first
match 21 to 4 which is an 84% he's uh
he's on pace for that type of win
percentage today I I would be surprised
if he if he wins by the same sort of
spread although Petrosian is a very good
blitz player so I'm you know and and and
he was only able to get four points
again against Magnus so we'll see if
Kadir can mix it up you highlighted Eric
that um he's got a limited repertoire
and so here he's gone back to the same
thing we saw the first time he had white
with e4 and Magnus but Magnus not afraid
to mix it up with a little bit of an
obscure obscure sort of I mean what did
he he played he played nice c6 on all
right one right that was fun I did I
wasn't even paying attention to that but
that was fun and you played that in all
of man as well the thing is we it's been
about a year and a half of blitz battle
speed chess championships and one thing
people sometimes assume is oh the lower
rated player is gonna do better in
bullet that's when there's more mistakes
and whatnot but the last matches
Geoffrey Zhong against MBL a very
competitive good stage and in bullet
that's we're gonna be able to pulled
apart a bit I mean also the chess960
checker did really well but the bullet
portions the hybrid of players have been
doing some damage right and I guess it
is yeah so it is not gonna get easier
it's actually going to be harder it's
harder to keep pace with with these guys
with last time they're there
that is do you think that the faster the
time controlled the more just intuition
and talent shines through right there's
less of an opportunity to calculate your
way through that intuition I I've always
said that having done a lot of these
matches even when I thought the higher
rated player wouldn't be as good and
bullet they always show that when the
gloves come off and intuition takes over
they're just you know they just shine
the faster the time control gets ya and
it also helps that we're in the Internet
age where almost all the top players are
well versed in bull they just like
playing it these guys are young
ambitious and all the time controls and
and it's a there's no stigma against
bullet you know i people we
traditionally don't play blitz don't
play bullet i think that's pretty much
being eroded because of we just look at
the top 10 standings Tommy how many
experts there are there yep alright so
Magnus has put this night on before is
he worried about Bishop to c3 coming or
he always has night a to hear what you
have a tap 'iz ition like this for the
fans let's teach him about some pawn
structure where you've you've got more
spaces white but you lack sort of entry
points right it white lacks squares and
and plans so how would you evaluate this
position I mean white that's not more
space and there's more pieces on the
board you do that favors forever yeah if
you have more space and more pieces you
just got more room to maneuver with the
the Queen side is locked in so the
actions gonna take place on the Kings
side and whoever manages that better
the problem with ganging up on this
night on before is that Magnus might
allow that to occur and put a piece on
c5 which is going to open up in a trader
I'm sorry sugar yeah based on his
opening choice he is ambitious this game
with black so as you said that the place
probably gonna come on the Kings side I
was highlighting as you were talking
that black has ideas of nine to four
there's also f5 coming sort of a Kings
Indian style and Magnus indeed leads
with the knight are we gonna see f5 yeah
we are you just go yeah straight in to a
King's Indian Danny black is happy when
the Queen side is closed in the Kings
Kings and yes usually white who just
tries to open it up and just get it in
there before black as he initials well
look at that tactic night c2 that's that
important piece that Bishop on a3 once
that falls yeah that I'm not for a
secured Bishop on e7
I might say this is a good version of
the Kings eating because a [ __ ] 27 is
also not locked in like that Bishop on
Jesus at yeah well you highlighted and I
think that was instructive for our
members that even if even if let's say
white had been able to give up the
bishop on before one thing that Eric
pointed out is that the dark squares
being so locked up white really doesn't
have a lot of counter play to make up
for blacks play on the Kings side and
now Magnus gets the best of everything
with Knight to c2 he's able to get rid
of that dark square bishop and keep his
attack going so this looks good for
black I mean we discuss White's bishops
he's stuck with this Bishop man on that
for now it's not a not happy Bishop it's
a the pawn on c4 pawns on e4 it's not a
nice not nice Bishop here it's not an
open position there's no freedom here
not not White's favourite Bishop I'll
tell you what Magnus has his favorite
snacks go and he hasn't stopped eating
he's pulling a full MBL here Eric he
hasn't stopped eating for the entire 5
minute portion no that's there might be
a new trend
I don't need a lot of snacks in the
middle of their in their streams that's
nice
just liquids being consumed then liquid
liquid not not snacks right all right
well you got you four so one thing that
always becomes a question here is just
black it's but I can have enough to
check me right because if you don't your
King can sometimes end up being open in
the long run especially if white does
get some sort of penetration on the a
file so how do you see this attack
developing where black makes sure he's
able to kind of take care of business on
the Kings side well I'm not entirely
sure that's gonna happen because black
hasn't sacrificed anything so he's not
all in on the attack okay wow you would
like to open up position h 5 h 4g
followed by g3 because the dark squares
they can open up will be very vulnerable
nice the piece that white is lacking
here but otherwise black may have a
positional approach just improve that
[ __ ] 27 go to g5 put the King on g7
maybe just slowly slowly pusher because
what's his white half why does
absolutely nothing here there's no no
play right if you're white you sometimes
wish in these structures you can put a
piece on e4 and block a on the light
squares but here is just not an option
for white because you know you don't
want a self pin the knight to the Queen
and your bishop on everyone is already
passive like but it's one of those
structures Eric where if white just had
a few more moves right if white was
several moves ahead and maybe had this
night on e1 just put it on e4
instead White's doing okay right you've
got a blockade of the squares but
because whites pieces are passive it
makes it even harder to deal with this
coming plan here yeah I mean all whites
pieces are bad this is how does white
stabilize here you need to win that
efore square you need to get a knight
there which sort of plugs the position
but black is too quick the Queen's on f6
can go to g6 it can reinforce that it
can each for h5h for this this is close
to lost to me in the sense that I think
it's going to snowball very quickly if
white ever you know I think a lot of
players here Danny would be grasping for
hair of the move like work a seven I
play working up seven is black and I say
once you got next right and you just
want nothing you have no more pieces to
throw into the fires so if you have to
if you have to just backpedal against
Magnus you're in for a long night Magnus
has created light square problems we
know what those are all about I'm pretty
sure jay-z raps about those all the time
so we've got issues on the white squares
and now there's even threats of
discovery maybe this Bishop can move to
c2 and Magnus jumps into f2 so so the
the wheels are coming off here but but
can good dear no I don't know that he
can you wish again you had a few moves
if you were white to play things like f3
and get the night on e1 out but there's
just no option there's no liberation
coming when you've got these two bishops
poking in on on all these diagonals so
yeah trouble here for white and what
this fine indicates this block is gonna
keep the Queen's and all the pieces on
the board because that that pawn could
potentially potentially be weak in an
endgame where the Kings can roam but
with the Queen's and heavy pieces on the
board that's going to provide mating
opportunities for black in the
initiative and so he's just going to
keep the pieces on the board and I just
could make threats make threats make
threats Baccarin threats pressure on f2
but that indicates yeah he is going to
go for for me at this game he fours a
nice move everybody reminder why
couldn't take it of course because if
Knight takes Bishop takes Queen takes
checkmate at the end when the smoke
clears so so why doesn't all defensive
mode even backs up the rook from a 3 to
a 2 just to keep an eye on this f2 pawn
so everything eric is saying is is
coming true
which is not good for for Agadir he
hasn't really moved from his position
yeah yeah I'm just a bit distracted here
because I'm also checking guests into
the hotel as some people on Twitch I
have mentioned that right I'm doing
double duty here with my my attire
commentating on chess and being that's
right that's right well you know what
either that or a a busboy in a nice
restaurant I'm pretty sure that's the
thing right it says you're you're seen
but not heard in that outfit but you
look good
I like the black tie look I
I don't like whites position here
although Magnus has been unable to break
through so far I guess now Agadir is
gonna shuffle his ponies until Magnus
make something happen but he does yeah
he's very happy to put on that out of
your three negatives so quickly so
there's a tactic we need to find your
daddy is there something coming with
because why would he do it there's
there's something there's something
lurking here well now c4 falls so great
X was the question was why couldn't
white take with the pawn I guess I just
didn't want to give up the F file due to
Queen f6 and then things like Bishop g4
I I think also you take you take what
the pond that you one is the most
pathetic piece possibly say for example
night c2 he runs into Bishop e2 yep
turning me yep I'm just gonna highlight
that you have nice c2 runs into Bishop
e2 forking made on f1 everybody and the
pawn on c4 this okay age five okay so
now you check you play rook e1 and you
check on it too and then after King goes
back to g1 so Rick it to Kim Ji Won and
there's a monkey - coming - yes Ricky -
Ricky - that's right Ricky - and rook G
- right okay - 93 with G to check if the
King goes into the corner runs into
Bishop f3 so the King has to give up
that age phone and that h1 is the
fastest piece on the board so yeah this
is just a and combine that with time
pressure it's almost impossible to be
white here I mean we're commentating
here Dani but look at the time she's 2
minutes 15 - 15 - 2 minutes to fit I
mean he's up for full 2 minutes on the
clock and a 5 minute game I mean you
might as well be AB apiece Kadir is
frustrated he
he lets out a cuff and sits back Magnus
is in cruise control right now Mike
Klein confirms he's also seen Magnus
have plenty of snack time during
classical game so Magnus is a snacker he
likes to keep that brain and brain
pumpin G moves in twitch on the twitch
chats that's very fitting the speed
chess championship sponsored by
masterclass because that's because
that's exactly what we're getting first
of all thank you for that thanks for
mentioning our sponsors masterclass and
yeah you're right we're all we're all
getting a front-row seat to Magnus
Carlsen smashed ur class today yeah I'm
curious from the audience so Magnus
scored 84 percent against Petrosyan
laughter does the audience think I'll be
over under that today that's a high
percentage like people talk about I mean
Magus is the number one ranked player in
the world so even if he wins a match he
may perform lower than his rating but
when he's putting up numbers like that I
mean we're talking about like 3000 level
performances which is not something not
something we see very much in chess yeah
he's uh he's hasn't lost yet of course
once he does lose he will drop below
3000 a whole lot of points with it but
right now he's uh he's on pace for 3100
if a car Nakamura is watching we know
he's frustrated hates when anybody else
is is higher rated and blitz or bullets
so although probably Magnus he's okay
with all right well we got another one
of these another one of these peers with
with a bishop on g4 and unlikely
pressure coming to d4 by black but now
it's now the colors are reversed right
this time Magnus is white and Magnus is
gonna play is gonna play 95 here maybe
that there's too many trades there but
that's a bit funny Magnus is copying
almost identically the position they had
in the first game which didn't yield
anything and okay I think he is gonna do
better in slope positions than good air
and he's up three three games but not
the most ambitious attempt to punish the
appearance which
is is an opening that deserves
punishment is it as bad as the French
I'm a French blur Amano I knew you were
I was just trying you and you and you
and lots of other people that it just
says somehow so how did that happen how
did you accidentally start playing the
French tell the fans I didn't I was it
was like the first opening somebody
showed me and and since I didn't study
chess I went with it and just played it
even though the positions were bad
alright I promise that's my that's only
my that's my second to last French joke
in the day so don't worry alright well
now we have 95 coming and the knight on
f6 is pinned you said it's not the most
ambitious way to punish the peers but it
looks like somehow when the same
structure occurred before Magnus got the
D file as black and got the knight city
4 here it feels like White is one step
ahead of black maybe eliminating the
knight on f6 and putting the pony on d5
maybe just thought cousins done anything
wrong he's playing how Magnus played in
the first game and that Queen on c1 to
me looks misplaced he's doing this but
Eric as you said before the reason why I
couldn't do this is cuz II four was
falling and now I think he'll play c3
Magnus and just kind of protect you for
I feel like he's following the advice
you gave Kadir as white in that previous
game that's very fair and he's gonna get
c3 by bishop on g7 is not the best piece
on the board it's gonna take a while for
that to become effective white might
actually pose a question with h3 at some
point maybe d4 before where does that
clean undies on c5 go because g6 might
run into just like some before the
threat right now before Queen d6 96 we
got material yes so somehow the
structure seems very same very similar
but Magnus is is is a little bit ahead
and in his accuracy and he managed to
achieve protection of his weakness and
establishment of his strength on d5 so
Kadir going into a bit of a think tank
here leaning in Magnus hasn't stopped
moving he's probably listening to music
- don't worry we'll hit him up we'll hit
him up with whatever music he's
listening to last time it was Taylor
Swift remember when he said that I do
know we are all like Taylor Swift I was
yes yep okay so
Kadir takes on a three and is headed for
simplification knows he can't compete on
the D file wants to get an obstacle
Bishop bending if the Knights come
forward if before Queen d6 that knight
on c6 is out of the way so ninety six is
no longer an option that discovered
attack on the cool right the Queen
chucks herself on d6 and she's still
able to protect he's seven so I think is
gonna keep the piece on the board but
the problem with move like 93 is Bishop
h6 now becomes good a good move
thank you diagonal yeah nice and that
before doesn't seem like it's going
anywhere so he knows we might be three
but with a swishing oh I didn't even see
that yeah the point everybody if Queen
takes Knight takes even check inter
missile white wins a piece so his idea
here is that I think he's gonna win the
d7 square unless Queen e6 is played but
Queen e6 I'm I started saying white use
that c5 square for the Queen you play h3
Bishop g4 but this was nice this was a
good read by Magnus that valuable time
game is gonna get him a good version if
they enter an endgame there's still two
rooks and a knight on the board besides
office of bishops so I know means a draw
and he definitely I think he's already
here he knows after the first few games
that if he takes good air into these
long games there's a percentage goes up
well and he takes the c5 square as we
said and the key is that even if the
Queen's come off the board whoever has
the the access point first right whoever
gets to the D file and then gets threats
on the seventh rank so this is just
really tough for Agadir to get out of it
now that night is gonna relocate itself
to e3 and and maybe maybe eventually
come back into one of these light
squares d5 or c4 I mean the problem here
is these are maneuvering games this is
really where I think Magnus would would
be be very comfortable right not sharp
openings
no pressure gates Magnus is his king is
like the safest King on earth every
single game is just always always easy
to play right I'm not in that sense
there's no practical pressure
whenever Magnus is facing a tough
decision it's oh how do I stop the
position from being dead equal it's not
like he sees any critical choices that
oh I might be much worse here oh I might
know there hasn't hasn't made a doesn't
have been in any uncomfortable spots yet
I mean this is the thing and speech as
people go and tilt and that's really how
you put some points on the board at a
certain moment and but something has to
happen you know it doesn't happen
randomly and he needs to get that one
draw or trick Magnus or something but
right now this is only gonna get get
worse the light squares are now very
weak the bishop on g7 is still a problem
these whites getting ready to maybe put
that bishop on c4 that's a great
diagonal you can also be in force light
squares a4 you can play those like g3 if
you want to just give space to your king
but you got the D file you got a well
placed Queen night on e7 doesn't have
squares you're not painting a very good
picture for Agadir right now I'm not I'm
not this is this is really he needs to
make some adjustments with his with his
approach yep well it's it's hard to make
adjustments like you said he has a
limited repertoire and it seems that his
repertoire is not one that that is that
it's a very challenging one for Magnus's
a few weaknesses if we can even say that
Magnus Carlsen has weaknesses but it's
we've you know you mentioned that you
know Magnus I think when he's challenged
in sharper theory or more complicated
positions less of a maneuvering game
it's just okay he's still the world
champion but you know this is this kind
of game we're seeing is right up Magnus
Ali and I I can't I can't disagree with
you though I wish I could add more more
like there's more fireworks here but
right now I think Bishop c4 is coming a
force coming the light scores are gonna
be grinded crimey
each fighter is a good move it took him
way too long to do that and that's I'm
surprised you got less spaces black and
you're under pressure
you're gonna take more time to solve
your issue see what's the play Bishop h6
he wants the others king on g7 just took
way too long to figure that out
right well Magnus is taking a bit of a
think now but as you said he's deciding
how he wants to convert on this as he is
he gonna put the bishop on c4
play some more patient move like you
know I mean I I'm guessing a lot of this
moves it's not because
it's I'm putting calculation and it's
just I'm just enjoying his position as
much as he is he's up so much time he's
got I stayed and he has come up with
something yeah yeah f6 is probably
forced well f6 no I probably put my
bishop back on g7 oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
that would be bad he's just gonna wait
for mistake so something he's passed
that as well he doesn't need to come up
with something urgent here maybe you
play h4 maybe you play King G - okay h4
might be one of blocks
ideas are just trying to gain some space
or provoke something but issues issues
we got issues you got them - right oh
yeah that's a non oh I do have issues
yeah all right a four is played so all
all the doom and gloom aside although I
guess it is pretty clear that now down
on time pressure or down on a time
pressure again for a good deal this is
only gonna get worse wait your king on
yourself and shuffler your king back and
forth it's still symmetrical structure
it's not any material but this time
situation you could be even up the pond
and you're gonna lose the game you just
gotta play faster right
yeah you get in Swindell territory right
with no time on I don't even think a
dear realizes he's about to lose on time
he doesn't know but I mean Khedira qadir
just loses on time and he didn't even
really realize that he was down on time
so that's that's definitely
disappointing for good dear and the next
game has started so no connection issues
either I mean Kadir has a super strong
connection from everything we can see
here on our oh wait no actually it just
dropped a little bit so it looks like he
is actually having not the ideal
connection here to the server I wonder
if that was part of part of why he lost
track of his time but we'll see you can
see those little bars right there next
to as uh his name that he doesn't have
as solid of a connection he's got some
lag as the connection says before
reaching the bars Danny I see the 0.0
beside his name
he's got to get a half point on the
scoreboard I mean you're playing Magnus
he's I mean it's gonna be one of the
most intimidating players to play in the
world right anyone knows how good he is
your confidence is only getting
shattered with this you need you need
some sort of you need some life yep this
is his game with Wyatt he's playing well
he's not putting Magnus he's not playing
the sharpest line right the sharpest
line here is is the variations with
Bishop f4 on move on move six right
rather than g3 yeah and white in that
line everybody intends to move the Queen
and if you can't get castled long and
try to get an attack so Kadir playing
where he's comfortable in his repertory
plays a more solid g3 approach but again
sometimes Styles make the mismatch even
worse right Eric where it's like
obviously Magnus Carlsen would be
favored either way but right now Kadir
is playing solid maneuvering chess but
he's up against the best solid maneuver
or maybe of all time right I mean it's
just not it's just not an ideal matchup
for his style I would agree I played him
did your online quite a bit he can he
knows his systems very well he plays
very quickly he's very sharp classically
but he's facing Magnus here where Magnus
doesn't make mistakes
you can play like Magnus can just play I
mean any surface surfer splendors where
he's just getting squeezed to death but
otherwise he's a very very for blitz you
know he can play super quickly you can
rattle out the opening and just play
with less space but the thing with
Magnus is Magnus manages space so well
whereas a lot of people you can have a
ton of space in blitz games but you get
a long time you get indecisive and you
start blundering and we've all faced
those guys who are very good in blitz
they might get even get bad positions
but they they just play those positions
a bit better and a bit quicker but
Magnus is not not the guy to fall for
that
yeah agreed and here so Kadir mixes
things up a little bit with this movie v
sacrificing the center pawn for the b7
pawn strategically you like that you
like that a little bit forged dere right
separate some blacks queenside pawns and
and now Magnus using an active approach
rather than rather than defending the e5
pawn plays a move Bishop before
sort of an inviting simplification I
guess we developed I would like this
maybe but I don't see how you unravel
yeah white can't take here everybody on
e5 just to show you the tactics Bishop
takes c3 followed by rook to d1 as Bob's
your uncle as they'd say as they say and
don't they say Bob's your uncle
in Canada north of the border well I
think you guys talked about that in the
last yeah really I really haven't heard
of maybe if I were to you once or twice
but no to me I'm not familiar with it
but okay then I'm on said he was yeah no
it depends on depends on the parts count
is a big country right and yeah we got a
few different phrases all right well I
actually do have an uncle named Bob
named Bob Bob yes our Klaus Magnus
switching to drinking straight out of
the gallon my mom always yelled at me if
I did that if I drink straight out of
like the orange juice bottle or gallon
that's a bachelor thing to do I'm sure
the chest bras are drinking straight out
of the bottle a lot but depends on which
bottle but no anyway what do we got here
we've got Carlson finds a way to get
active he's got the rook on the seventh
rank here he goes again chugging away
that looks like milk
that's I mean if that's milk that's just
nasty we got to talk to Magnus about
that you can't drive that much milk I
mean do you remember the milk
commercials uh drink whatever I saw the
rock I think Dwayne Johnson he was dying
and the other guys drink azmuth you know
maybe he's uh preparing for one of those
milk mustache I would see Magnus on on a
milk mustache commercial I'm lactose
intolerant so ooh I'm addicted to cheese
and dairies so cheese is good cheese is
good it's you know currently got my wife
and I on the verge of divorce I'm no
cheese cheese cheese it's a big problem
so but we'll deal with that another time
[Music]
yeah I don't want to take on c2 because
that's just the worst observation time
game with my week light squares it's
white around my king I probably play
Bishop g4 but maybe you can just take on
c2 and just enjoy that joy that Magnus
is in no trouble here I can say that
Dani even material a bit of an imbalance
but not one that favors white so he goes
for d4 I think Magnus will probably take
on c2 as you said yep and now the a for
pawn starts to start to speak to you
maybe a little bit if if black and
maneuver this bishop on on e6 into some
squares you also might see that bishop
on e6 head into a square like d3 right
where it supports efore and kind of
holds the B file yeah no I mean what's
going on you you challenge on the B file
what black trades off once plays rookie
- he's gonna win that a pawn right I
think blacks King is safe as far as I
can tell okay he's bailing out with
Bishop before but this is gonna be again
a push for black locks not winning but I
prefer to have blacks Bishop rather than
whites Bishop because of the weaker King
right and the presence of two boats on
the board especially White's work on a
box for concie - so Magnus with a
slightly better position time is even
but he gets to pusher one thing you
gotta watch out for is work he filed
rook coming I get the a5 pawned yeah but
Magnus might be able to give up the D a
pawn if he gets enough pressure whereas
you as you said yeah but the bishop on
c4 does control f2 so he has to do that
in a good way because you'll never get
your works on the second - anywhere near
what White's king of if you can't we
puts the bishop on d5 I wonder with this
open diagonal here potentially weak
light squares Eric if there's an idea of
rook c2 b2 and and maybe a trade on the
on the first rank some sort of mating
that possible against the whites King in
the future this is a nice smooth this is
nice to see father Bishop takes rook
takes c3 and the bishop goes back to e3
because h3 was hanging right and now
maybe hang up on a four punch yeah I
want to go for a meeting that Danny but
let's say you checked me on the
background let's say I have no real
Kanye one right check me I play King H -
you checked me again I play King g3
where's the mate
right you are making progress but it's
gonna take some it's gonna take some
maneuvering
so now Magnus is taking his time trying
to figure out how to gang up on the a
for pawn without letting his a5 pawn
become a target so that's the issue of
black is gonna get any winning chances
here
Magnus actually down a minute on time so
at Lisa's as far as camp good dear
you're happy to see him he's meet up a
little bit and not napkin he's probably
not gonna lose this one because of
pressure at least I'll knock on wood and
say that mm-hmm if he's playing this
musica one for me Rock a seven magnus
gives a check on the back rank and then
maybe he's gonna play some sort of g5
move maybe he's going for me with this
move because that's what rook a seven
okay King and supersets work a seven it
seems like they don't have a good way of
defending the a five fun
yeah I agree and and and I agree with I
I have an idea of going for the light
squares but but I agreed with your
assessment I don't see anything more
than a perpetual unless okay I guess
there are there ideas here with with
rook h1 check and then you check on g1
and maybe go to g2 and get a discovery
you can't do that if your bishop on d5
is hanging but there are ideas where
maybe the rook transitions to the g2
square yeah well you need to keep
White's King boxed in so you don't want
it to go to go to f4 because then it can
start running down all over the place
right so so you can give that first
check but then that's why I'm looking at
the g5 move and saying okay maybe that
keeps everything tied it may be g5 now
maybe g5 after yeah and if if something
like rook a 7 is played and g5 comes in
and rook takes a 5 like I said hits the
bishop on d5 with tempo so black can
take a draw if he wants to play tickle
on each one and g1 and just get a
perpetual yeah right now goose a nub is
playing well this is this game I we're
not seeing more than a perpetual at best
for for Magnus let's see how he tries to
checkmate black or if he's checked me
whether if he's going to be okay with
that
whoa no no exactly the line we thought
about it maybe he'll just play tickle
yeah I'm a 7 was gonna fall anyways give
your King some more breathing room rook
check oh visual f3 is shinobi 3 it might
still be a perpetual Bishop f3 rook f5
so Ricky 5 now just continue harassing
will still see rookie 5 Ricky 5 is it
possible that rook takes g4 check is the
move it is that is something and then
black can argue that he's a better
structure on the Kings side and you can
give a pawn uh-huh but this was
unnecessary this was unnecessary to to
allow because
if you just made it one more preparatory
move I think you could force force to
draw so Magnus is going for this and he
may still take the draw or maybe now he
decide he has here's the luxury of
choice here
right shuffles bishop if he moves and it
still may be perpetually can play Bishop
f3
he always has a draw at hand is he gonna
strike for more we'll see yeah here
comes rook f5 I think as you said and
the question is does the bishop and I
can win another pawn here or takes F to
check but the only question is is my
bishop survived and I think it does but
what's the right one King goes to f1
maybe now and gets out of all those
discovered checks but but then Magnus
will well see that the issue is is now
it's three on one on the Kings side so
if he plays a move like Bishop d7 here
it could be five I'm gonna play rook g3
and just try to transition into an
endgame so man who's gonna try to find
safety for that Bishop the whole point
everybody just for those who aren't
quite understand the reason the bishop
is stuck of course you can't move it
anywhere without the king king oh let's
have a thought the rook hanging so so
now virtually three there might be a
bishop takes g5 and things still get
traded off I want to go rook g3 and I
want to okay no this isn't right no man
needs to find a bit more finesse here
maybe I wonder if it's possible in
Russia three if I can take c6 and take
h6 probably that's not a good rook
ending to go to against Magnus but the
other issue with rook to g3 is is is
Bishop f2 possible now getting a temple
on both the book and the bishop so this
is oh-three work out five okay I want to
play rook g3 but the problems working
through this King F to write for Omaha
uh-huh okay King f2 is a big issue in
that line otherwise we get our Magus is
taking his time yeah I mean he's gonna
do everything he can to keep winning
chances that's what he wants but we're
not seeing a safe way to get the finish
up away from the rook without losing our
own rook on g2 mm-hmm okay so he goes
for a three and I guess we expect rook
f5 again yep okay Brooke g3 king of to
work takes f3 you can check on h2 and
play rook a to after and I think you're
winning the a four pond
but that's against the bishop so rook
rook to a3 King up to work age three
rook takes off I think he's uh huh he
agrees with you that that is gonna be
his last chance to have a wedding that's
nice you wouldn't oh he's got another
tempo to gain and after you should be
for inter miss Oh didn't see Oh Magnus
Oh Magnus classic classic mag town I now
what's the deal I'll play rook e5 here
rookie five how does he get out of it I
thought he was gonna go rook takes
oh yes f5 at the end of some of those
lines he's got like okay good there was
transition but maybe the idea was that
he had moves like f5 at some point
protecting everything what's going on
here this is a popular although now yeah
yeah for sure this is a draw Wow
yeah why can take because because I
can't get my king yeah yeah you have
this blockade where the bishop is on the
diagonal always ready to sacrifice from
Salons it was just I didn't see why he
needed Bella but maybe maybe there was
something thank you what's up in his
chair and leans in he was a little bit
too relaxed getting three victories are
sorry for victories on the board before
Kadir gets any points and now looks like
Magnus might be about to drop his first
half point mm-hmm yeah and instruct you
let's see what he does here he's gonna
even if it's a draw he's gonna extract
the maximum before that happens and it's
and it's important to even if you know
the theoretical evaluation to to put as
much pressure on your opponent and
you're right though he actually did get
though the ideal see everyone just so
you understanding if the if this dark
square bishop is on the c1 h6 diagonal
it's just a draw already but that's the
king can never get to e5 and support
those bonds but here exactly maneuver
something the bishop is yeah I know it
looks like gideros got it figured out
see as long as the bishop can kind of
play tickle everybody and attack the
base pawn the jeep on blacks King is
never gonna be able to get an ideal
square so he's gonna put the business 1
inch 5 maybe right Magnus wants to put
the mission 1 h5 because that prevents
this Bishop from leaving the diagonal
f-for check coming in five a name king
of seven right so that yeah but if you
page five the problem is a six comes in
so that's right yeah that's right now
you can't you can't do both unless can
you put the bishop on see it Danny
but that doesn't maybe that doesn't do
much yeah Bishop one see it would be the
last chance though you're right okay now
he's all Lynn he goes through this more
that's gonna be a draw here yeah he's
off food rods it's a drug good good
stuff from Kadir yeah very good
defensive technique and and just again
for the beginner audience members the
idea is remember you can't mate with a
king and Bishop so qadir is always ready
to give up that Bishop for the two pawns
which just puts black in a position
there's just no way to win that no way
for the King to make progress without
the bishop giving itself up so speaking
of Magnus's openings he plays B through
again a nice giri tweeted that he can
see the influence of bent Larsen on
magnus carlsen openings last week did
you see that tweet yes and so what is
that what he's referring to Magnus has
openings that he played at the Isle of
Man and luckily now would be three right
no no actually it wasn't he's being
cheeky I was actually on the broadcast
when they brought that tweet up and I
was trying to figure out how Magnus was
playing like Larsen because I don't
think he played p3 nah
the last name of his girlfriend is arson
ah I see I didn't know that other time I
met her afterwards but yeah that insider
information those along see I was on the
outside of that inside tweet joke and I
I didn't know me too me too and I was
just like on air trying to pretend to be
cultured and connect madness like 1970s
Larsson and right just like the only
thing that made me remember that was
that he just played b3 because that
would be playing like Larson but but he
didn't actually play b3 of the Isle of
Man no yeah okay well interesting stuff
there the we do have a a Larson style
game here with b3 the nimzowitsch Larson
attack is is the name of this opening
but what exactly is going on here I
don't even know I already like whites
position and I
even know why tell me why do I like
whites position probably the exchange of
h4 and h5 guys Super Bowl four for white
if black castles King side I don't know
it it also looks looks good to me but I
can't quite put my finger on it
maybe you and I could establish a
relationship like that where I just say
what I feel and then you translate it
kind of like Angry Obama could you do
that for me like Danny says a chess
opinion and then Eric translates what he
means with the X's and O's well getting
I'm not sure I want to try to think
figure out what what you're thinking
with my head might be detrimental to
telling on I'm not sure I'm not sure but
I'm willing to try it feet alone in that
but yeah we like that I'd like to have a
chess translator sometimes to make me
feel like I blender less but all right
what's going on here this is my kind of
chess though this is this is obscure
we're gonna get some sort of weird
tactic some sort of attack I like white
jf4 here well why does the initiative
because what's gonna get you for now for
and he's put a rock on g1 and have this
f5 little break yet blocks not that
comfortable casting on the Queen side
because Queen d7 there might have been
Bishop b5 things like that this this
looks awkward for for block to say the
least and now this is nice
offering to trade off the dogs for
bishops and put that Queen on c3 yep we
need a the reason that works is because
blacks dark squares are probably much
weaker than whites dark squares long
term everybody here comes the Queen to
c3 and queenside castle so Bishop e5
first I'm gonna tease get rid of the
structure the Bishop d7 here maybe then
I go Queen c3 and Knight f6 I was gonna
say let's put a pony on f6 and then we
got threats up Knight d5 even followed
by f4 and although we have to watch
Queen ephod my trade everything off and
kill our fun is Queenie forever is it
ever killing now is this fun to head to
an end game no it's not especially cuz
it's a bad buy that game yeah you got
issues here if 95 you lose the game
immediately with 95 yeah absolutely no
this is uh
if 95 95 Forks the Queen and the
checkmate everybody okay he's doing this
but this is a terrible endgame I've
calculated it to Queenie farm
listen eight-six I want to know I think
just F for no F for Bishop singing sorry
okay so you can't play a four right away
you have to take first but then the
bishop takes and you can't get up for
right that's right now it takes these
seven one since the Queen takes b5 so
actually this isn't as good as I thought
well Queenie thought I was worried about
this was actually what if he just backs
it up maybe Magnus plays Bishop e2
threatens to move f4 and tries to
continue to get to that nice endgame
that we like
keep on f6 and get that pond enough I
agree with that I agree I like you
should be too and again Magnus just
seems to make this type of game look so
easy how quickly he gets a positional
edge where it feels like he's in control
I like Bishop e2 I even like a four kind
of doing the same idea just to protect
the bishop oh okay what does he see
and he's saying the endgame is nice
because of my 906 Oh Queen c3 King c3
bishop c6 I'm going to play rook e1 with
g5 and play f4 f5 and create all these
weaknesses all with an arrow not six so
Queen c3 King c3 Bishop c6 bucks
what blocks gonna be White's gonna play
E for I'm gonna use the G file and
you're going to eventually push push
those bonds because that that net in
Essex can't be a post the rook can't go
to e8 in e6 how do you kick out that
name it's like a cattle and cattle a
knight on c6 and he plays e4 even before
trading Queens I was thinking he could
probably get the same type of idea by
trading Queens and then playing e4 but
maybe he didn't like rook d6 right rook
t6 and the king can go to the 87 exactly
okay interesting
I like now rook g1 route g5 forcing the
Queen trade he's not doing it but okay
this place against rook G 1 cos Queen
takes h4 Queen e3 not possible not
enough six things so this this seems
reasonable still have an issue though I
might play here for I might just like
slowly build up maybe od5 nice what if I
take what if I take Danny and play Queen
d5 okay so I'm not mating everybody my
queen is pet what women is that a
blunder Danny what if I take and put 25
I think he got you all excited without
that was a block worse he got not to say
wonder that was his first blunder and he
is yeah yeah no that queen is pin no no
mate there no mate Kadir has life
everybody we have lifts
magnus carlsen is a human being and you
know what I still think why it's okay
they need to apply Brooktree one next
even the Queen endgame the King goes the
d4 he plays out for that night on a
knight on f6 is still dominant the rooks
need open files so you're up in exchange
is good but you still need open files to
prove it
amazing amazing with that Blender I
think a deers gonna get a win here I'm
gonna say that even with Magnus I agree
with you in that white still has some
conversation but feels like there should
but although yeah look at that 911 the
e8 square and just how difficult that
makes blacks life to get the best out of
those rooks that's why you plays rook g1
right because he wants to prevent the d5
push if you can okay look at that though
right now we have looks like we have
some connection issues we're back we're
back and better than ever
back and better than ever this time my
office Internet died I thought it was me
because it happened to me the worst time
during the roll call
it's not you it's me Eric I know you've
heard that before I've heard that before
I've heard it actually way too many
times this year this this time it really
it really is true and you can know that
you got out of got out of a bad
relationship with me but I have
apparently I'm back online office
Internet is good to go magnus carlsen
one while we were gone and he won and he
actually did what I said it was good
stuff he it was practically a tough
position you're up in exchange but that
Knight is a monster and well it wasn't
an easy conversion so yes right he won
that game down the exchange
I wasn't even I wasn't here for that
that was that's an epic turn of events
in this match right I mean his inability
to lose games even if he's blundering
the exchange Erik that's a that's a
problem oh for sure no it was um you
know mega splendour that game randomly
from from a favorable position Kadir
really needs to needs to start putting
more pressure on and not waiting for
mistakes but by creating pressure
and and posing problems and giving
Magnus just just positions that are a
bit more than or rational or but it's
gonna be very tough because as I said
he's not the he's got a pretty narrow
repertoire and he's sort of a yep sticks
to what he's good at and he's just
facing a basic form a right now when you
get to that level let's talk a little
bit about it so good dear you saying
here's a pretty narrow repertoire and
when you think of you know 27 north or
2700 GM's which he's not quite that but
you think these guys should be able to
kind of mix it up employ the things but
is that is that not having like a second
or a trainer or a coach to kind of help
you expand he did say as of 2015 he's
kind of had no no coach he's um yeah
well I mean I noticed he's not playing
as actively as before and if you're not
playing as actively as before it's a bit
either tougher boring to study opening
all the time that you're not going to
use so so that also has to do with it
but this has brought him a lot of
success he's he's he's a formidable
blitz player who punches well above his
rating because you know he's knows the
system systems well very sharp
tactically and and it's just oh we're
still here the stream is off
I know it Rob for a second but it'll be
right I'll be right back in um I don't
know what's going on I'm it's nothing to
do with twitch or the server it's my
office here network bandwidth yeah I
sometimes have I literally have like
anxiety dreams about that like what
would we do if all the internet in like
my city just went off right now
I had this today because it happens to
me recently during a big it makes you so
anxious and frustrated cuz it's like
something so outside of your control and
right now I've troubleshooted with the
office and we actually have kind of a
full tech support here it's this is
really the only official chest comm
office but they say things are ok there
it might be our our cable provider
meaning our our cable in it I have no
idea of so let's hope it doesn't happen
again yeah I asked that about the coach
because you know Kadir said he hasn't
had really a trainer since 2015
he said that most the Azzurri players
don't and he thinks it's kind of holding
the Azzurri players back from reaching
the highest levels so it's an
interesting interesting point there when
we interviewed good deer before the
match that he you know he kind of said
that he feels like that's an issue right
now in his game he played for the
Azzurri Olympia to Olympia team in 2002
the as buddy le he's all he's usually on
board for for the Azzurri team look at
Magnus he's just rocking back and forth
here what's he even what's he doing I
don't know I never know what Magnus is
doing all right well about 15,000 at the
time those are pretty good numbers for
ya work for it we'll get back there
we've only got nine minutes left here in
the five minute portion so right now
it's pretty much been all the world
champion at the very least we're
learning something from Magnus Carlson's
master class all jokes aside the the
speeches championship is brought to you
by masterclass we'll talk a little bit
about Garry Kasparov's upcoming upcoming
course here and here in a moment but um
anyway only nine minutes left in the
five minute portion Derek and then we
have chess960 maybe Qadeer can can mix
things up when the pieces are randomly
placed on the board maybe he's gonna
have to take the initiative maybe this
game is it where he's down upon and he's
now playing see three willing to open up
Lions yeah this this is gonna he's gonna
have to maybe take a break you know they
got about a three minute break after yep
each each portion of the match and and
just figure out what he needs to do so
what's happening here if Magnus takes on
c3 are we even gonna see a move like
like even rock FC one just go all-in and
gambit open the Queen side to try to get
an attack I can see something like that
Magnus is probably looking at moves like
g5 right now if I already guess yeah you
want to play moves that mix it up yeah
yes yeah and here he he black it black
wants to open up lines against the white
King everybody pretty much a necessity
when you have Kings on opposite sides of
the board he's he's pretty slow white I
mean and getting me you know you know
you're slow when you're banking on your
opponent to sort of provide the files
for you
with a move like Ceres so yeah Knight
takes these seven is good vertices under
this is just great position for black
that each four move is being taken
advantage of here Danny as a first point
of contact and black block cuts the
initiative first yeah and after the big
trade if everything if it doesn't become
attack everybody where white gets the
play we were kind of thinking he might
get it's just gonna simplify into an
endgame where Magnus is up a pawn so
white has to White has to mix this up
and and right now I think he's just a
big trouble I don't know why Magnus is
thinking Queen take seems to be maybe he
doesn't want rook d1 I guess that's the
pin so he's debating whether to take on
d6 with them back yeah yeah that's fair
taking although although you might be
able to take with the Queen and play
Queen c5 after rook d1 uh-huh or queen
f4 and get a bit closer yeah all right I
think he'll go for the attack even you
could even take h4 and then try to Oh
beautiful right
I was looking if you go g4 you're gonna
win the pawn on d4 with tempo Knight
takes d4 right G floods along the net
going to you found might be a bit much
so yeah okay he's got some options here
Magnus taking his time to think about it
he was up a pawn so reminder everybody
he's not anxious to get this pawn back
and plays it I plays a nice prophylactic
move puts the King off of the open file
okay a lot of the tactics
Kadir seems tired he seems he seems
frustrated no surprise I mean obviously
he's he hasn't gotten any good positions
like he's just not getting like any
positions that yeah I think the best
position God was when Magnus blundered
the exchange and even that wasn't enough
and it was yeah you know even absolutely
blundered I wasn't it wasn't this
amazing position so here maybe it worked
c1 Peter Quinn on g3 but the problem is
black can play 95 at the right moment
and kill kill some of the fun here yeah
no no there's he's just playing with
that ice laid upon yeah I was gonna say
this didn't become the kind of attack we
thought it might be for black opening up
the Kings side but Magnus is doing what
he does best he's going to try to put on
positional clinic he now has the C file
he's got the week D pawn to gang up
against white wants fine 803 and force
block to play f6 so that then he six
becomes a target right so maybe a six
here King a seven a six on the board now
903 yeah after I've six probably
something like Sigma e60 six is it gonna
be target but black and gently move rook
down one square to c6 I was just about
to say if F six you can play queen GG
four and if Knight f4 there might be
shots with d5 so this is this is nice
now maybe Queen d6 or Queen c7 block is
just very comfortable that's a great
night on d5 White's knight on f3 is a
support is looking for is looking for
something better
maybe Knight black is just preparing to
eventually enter in on the on the C file
right whether that's c2 or c1 okay now
this is a position that he's gonna just
is not gonna go for something immediate
is gonna turn this easier to play
position into a time advantage and then
he's gonna go for something a bit more
concrete man you make it sound so easy
it is in this case because you just got
physical there's just no space for white
to maneuver with yeah you file better
night better time situation better pawn
structure you know it's all in favor for
Meghan's yeah now with this Nitra
treating it's just and I mean I was just
an old man watching Magnus just put on
the clinic too so just just sort of the
momentum is they very rarely someone
wins an open event like that end and and
finishes with a higher performance
rating you have this 2900 performance
rating by Magnus so he's in he's in good
form right now and so you can even
consider rook c2 here and give up just
about let's say can you go for tactics
if rook c2 Queen takes East six and then
you know you can I just don't think it's
necessary because it's harder for white
to play when there's no clear direct
lines to calculate I mean you know it's
easy to calculate
I win upon sir I give up on I went upon
back here as part of another pot here
where you have to make your own pressure
Hussein off has not done that at all
today he has not been able to create
anything on his own right everything
he's prepared if Magnus has already seen
and now he's afraid to put the knight on
e5
everybody cuz once the threat of taking
e6 is gone black can just gobble up the
b2 pawn so Kadir is having a thing do I
really want to put my knight back on h2
know he's gonna he's gonna brave closing
the e-file so will Magnus take me to
here maybe Knight f6 and play out for
and put the knight back and after
opening up the King side yeah yeah it's
not clear right if you go for this rook
ending maybe he's you know he doesn't
want to go for this because at the end
there's moves like rookie v attacking
all the pawns yeah I mean there is Queen
takes b2 here and I still think it's
probably good endgame for block the
Kings a bit closer and you're
temporarily up Lathon but it's probably
not necessary he's gonna find the best
version here
I trust trust Magnus well we'll find
across Magnus normally finds the best
version whether whether people want him
to or not right now good dear again
hoping for another month or so he goes
for the reckoning he's gonna go for the
line I suggested what's his thought what
does Magnus think about this he just
he's I guess he just likes that as you
said his King is in a better position
he's probably gonna win the a pawn and
have a couple of past pawns on the Queen
side so he's getting rid of first thing
he did was he's got rid of White's
potential of connected passed pawns
right on the King side and once that's
gone you eliminate most of you losing
chances and now it's simply a matter of
controlling the F pawn because otherwise
besides that he's doing well
kingdoms closer it's got two pawns there
nice move king b6 he's gonna play check
now everybody rook g4 check and bring
Brooke to g7 oh I guess I'll do it next
move but the point everybody as Magnus
knows he can get that rook in front of
the pawn with tempo so he didn't need to
rush getting the rook behind that's just
more accuracy in the endgame by the
world champion and we will trot we might
be letting the players know this is
their last five minute game Eric there's
only two minutes left on the on the
total five-minute clock here so
depending on how long this goes this
could be it it's gonna have to be a bit
precise here he played this move to stop
King out for King out for him King at
five or white gets that pawn going real
fast right this way this way
King d6 King e6 might be on top yeah
look what the King to get that for right
I'm not sure maybe you can play we got
five check okay here he wants to just
king d6 King D for and so maybe black
isn't gonna go back for the pawn maybe
black tries for B 5 and a 5 first mm-hmm
this is a game with high drawing chances
for Ferguson although fortunately that
that I've found distracts but black does
not have connected past bonds he might
get one B pawn or something but I don't
see how he ever gets those through
without giving I mean the def bond is
gonna roll so I'm not sure how he makes
progress here Magnus kind of shaking his
head there looks a little bit a little
bit yeah
so now Brooke work out for and the King
has to move and the King moves wall of
king b5 maybe I put my king on b3 if
King here no it's just uh it looks like
he's just sort of submitting that it's
gonna be a draw now and the reason
everybody if the white king is already
in front of the pawn not the dynamics we
saw in other scenarios where the goose
ain't house King wasn't ideal this is
the very easy draw for white whatever
your king is placed in front of the pawn
you're basically doing what white does
you sit tight look for your opportunity
for the rook to start giving checks and
the game is just gonna be a draw so
looking for my my official my official
staff to let us know you have officially
there is one more game they did get it
in under the time which means my my
clock my my game clock is is pretty much
accurate and the match has already
started right now we are we have just
reached the end of the five two and and
now so this will be the last classical
game and then we will have some chess960
do you think the players are conscious
of that clock or you guys generally tell
them and then
miss Li I think they're generally very
conscious I mean I've always been sort
of impressed by their ability usually
they kind of ask us hey was that the
last game or whatever they kind of keep
a track they know it's 90 minutes
roughly in fact they usually are
wondering why it goes over if they got a
game in in time they get to have one
more game that counts toward the score
though and goosing offs case I don't
think he's happy to get one more game
right now probably wishing he had a
break yeah well two draws it started off
with three zero four zero at least at
least it's not a not a shutout right now
and then he's on the board remains to be
seen who six two against petrosyan the
last time
Magnus played around one as a heavy
favorite right now six one is looking
real real good for him although he did
lose that 3,000 yeah you know that hurts
I'm pretty disappointed the no but
you're right I mean it's 6 to 1 it was 6
to 2 in the petroleum match where he
eventually went on to win 21 to 4 so
he's on pace Magnus is on pace to do
what he does and press and press the
many and press the masses the players
have been officially notified that this
is this is the last game and well I
don't know if you guys keep keep stats
as almost like swimming who sets the
record for the first lap it would 7 to 1
be the biggest score in a round one I
don't know if we keep trying I mean at
some point we need to get the Elias
Sports Bureau up and the somebody's got
to start keeping track of this Mike
Klein
our man's stab boy as he loves loves
being during these shows he anybody who
reads Mike's news report knows that he
has a love and affinity for for obscure
pop culture references Mike knows a lot
of information that I do not know
obviously he's a baseball fan so you do
the math know let us know or he'll say
Danny that's not a stat I know and then
I just don't ask so but alright we've
reached the end of the 5 to portion
everybody right after this there will be
chess960 so don't go anywhere
the chess960 games are always a ton of
fun regard
of regardless of the scores just always
interesting and sometimes educational as
well but right now it's dominant Eric I
mean give us give us any any thoughts
about what good deer would have to do to
have a have a turn around here ooh that
is that is a very very tough tough
question I know first then how hard is
to adjust mid-match when there's so much
adrenaline going on and and it seems
like you're playing against the wall
here who just does anybody any real
weaknesses in the case of Magnus that's
that's the that's a big question
you know I don't know what he goes for I
think he has to play faster and and and
start playing looser he's gonna have to
right stop some of these maneuvering
middle games be the bit more direct
confrontational be a bit more aggressive
Magnus is getting the initiative almost
every single game it's not even just
about the evaluation you know he's also
getting the initiative he's just getting
freedom and and he's doing that again
here he's up of almost 45 seconds on
time again and has the initiative on the
queenside everybody trying to pry open
this this light square on d5 if he can
but you know I obviously agree 100% I
didn't even I don't I didn't know nearly
as much about Kadir style as you do but
seeing them face off here it's becoming
really clear that this is this is almost
similar to a monkey or Meier went up
against Sergei coriaci and gordon being
a super solid very technical you know
just very very good in in in end games
but he played sergei Kaka and who was
all the things gorg meyer isn't just
that much better right and and it became
a really lopsided match despite the fact
that we know your admirer is a super
strong grandmaster and this is kind of
like what's happening to to Kadir here
right I mean he's just he's album he's
outmatched in terms of his style and
maybe he doesn't even have the ability
to mix it up yeah I mean
these these positions Magnus is well
also credits a Magnus for picking his
spots and not allowing any real
counterplay like in this game I was
looking at you can a better play is 9 th
3a move it is a move here he goes it is
in balance and you get a lot of squares
ok was wondering if Magnus if Magnus
missed that I mean looking at our at our
players it didn't Magnus didn't seem
like it usually wears his heart on his
on his sleeve there you can kind of tell
well see that's what we're looking for
94 daddy there you go ok now you know he
made a mistake for this Quidditch more
check so this is this is good that was
Magnus being too clever though right oh
yeah consciously allowed that history
there we go some tactics isn't in
balance Quinta except for 95 is coming
yeah they'll not clear that block it is
doing great there but it's an imbalance
and he did trick trick Magnus in that
sequence 95 yeah yeah probably gonna get
there by Bishop d3 block the diagonal
put a rook on b1 he's already got a
great book on c6 and just push that
seapunk down the court right and moves
like Bishop e5 are probably commonly met
by g3 although you have to be a little
careful with your bishop on d3 mm-hmm
that there's no tricks but but ok we'll
see we're good dear chooses to put the
Queen amazing again Magnus did sort of
get swindled there he missed the trick
but despite shaking his head and and not
being too happy it looks I would I would
still prefer white here I mean my this
is so good when he blunders he gets
playable positions nice if only it
happened to us it's like the world's
most interesting man like his blunders
are other people's good moves right the
okay he plays g3 first prophylactically
and then I think he's gonna do your idea
of putting the bishop on d3 maybe we're
going first
we actually don't even need to if you do
it properly probably just working one
yeah yeah everyone looks good and you
know if Kadir is all in on mixing it up
why not f5 right you got to do something
try to mix it mix the tactics up Magnus
trying to get the Queen's off the board
so he can just drive this C pawn
home with with no tactical worries so
I'm seeing quite I get a feeling Magnus
is very happy to play against these
fianchetto systems that Christina is
employing we're seeing a lot of end
games where positions where let's say
the Queen's are off now Magnus is saying
look I just got a good position because
your Bishop on Jesus lap but can't
really stop my my counter play right
middle the board so he enjoys playing
against that but she won't you said good
you're trying to avoid the Queen's race
but Magnus is not letting him get away
gonna force the Queen's off the board
come hell or high water as they say and
then again I like what you said the
bishop on g7 not as good as the knight
on d5 if we're comparing apples to
oranges and I think white just puts the
rook on c1 and eventually this C pawn
becomes a problem I was forced to do a
trade let's see here I'm trying to find
those like 97 check maybe that doesn't
work all those trades everything off
Magnus just trade and play f4 and then
you can do that you can do that he's
goofs a mob is down a minute a half
that's taking a long time on some of
those that sort of needs to a bit
quicker mm and we we actually lost Kadir
here via the camera again hopefully
that's not a sign of him struggling with
internet but he's complaining about
maybe six numbered pieces okay well yes
it's set up in mind here Dani we're an
item b6 pawn on c5 we can just push
these 67 down down the board to see it
did he lose them yep look good dear now
he'll be back he says he says he seems
to have a spotty connection that drops
him from time to time but should I shift
over or look good either way whatever
you want to do it man I mean I don't
want the fans to make too much fun of
your black tie again we know you're
going right from this to your Bell man
job no but but okay
the the game is looking like it's
heading toward a a tough one again for
forged ear this b-pawn being a little
bit more mobile than the deep on but
okay he's he's transitioned is he gonna
grab the gate upand you grab the coupon
I played b7 and Brooks see it's a bit
scary to allow he can do it but I think
this should be v was probably his idea
to hold b8 but maybe it's still not good
enough
honestly with 20 seconds maybe he just
didn't calculate well enough to know
this is bold this is both for sure so
Brooks see a bishop b8 for example and
then block is gonna have that a pawn
rolling down the board so it's the most
important part yeah decides he'll go
pick up the pick up the a pawn first
he's got that with tempo very nicely
done Danny
very nicely done now he's gonna wiggle
his way back to c8 is as we first want
and now that the a question is do you
play bishops before trying to trade off
those pieces then your knight goes back
to d5 you bring your king to d3 block
the deep bond and just put your work on
see it so maybe a Bishop c4 I might be
inclined to do I'm not sure I want to
bring my king into the game I want to
trade off the lights for bishops I want
it all you want it all you do you want
it all and you're probably gonna get it
all because even if there is an accurate
defensive approach for black I'm not
sure Kadir can find it under time
pressure yeah so I would like to play
Bishop 83 here but maybe Bishop b5 my
King's bucks and I wanna bring my
kingdom d3 damage right this should be
six right put the bishop out of the way
so we can as you said activate the King
put it on d3 and and white is white is
holding all the cards he's always in
this position
Magnus doesn't need to find a knockout
blow he's up so much time you just
but improves his pieces he's always
ready for a pleasant game and just wait
for a block to implode under this severe
pressure yeah well
Kadir has to figure it out get himself
out of being swindled but before he gets
too low on time oh they're very nice
night to be six inviting women capture
get a queen yeah I'm expecting the
bishop chief or maybe Bishop d2 if
Bishop e6 Bishop c4
I think Bishop e2 is a little nice shot
here yeah it doesn't work a deflection
if black would take it everybody white
would be capturing on f8 and then for
King on d7 I think but yeah it looks
nice oh look at the time this is just
yeah just not enough time for gatir and
he goes down on time and just like that
Magnus has a Magnus has a seven one lead
breaking his own record I have
confirmation from my Klein that the
biggest lead we had had previously was
Magnus Carlsen 6-2 lead last year in the
first round and he is best at himself
he's bested himself he's now he's now
got a seven one lead on the books in the
books as they say and we have our first
chess960 game this looks almost this
looks as close to a normal game as we as
we ever see Eric yeah this is by the way
a seven to one now I mean that that's
the biggest score ever in the first
second now crazy
he needs a score win here I rate his
chances in chess960 higher than any
other time control or you know variation
left yeah well any sort of randomness
get Magnus out of his comfort zones got
to make you happy but right after this
everybody there'll be a small break and
then we'll be moving on to the three
minute portion things will only speed up
from here so this is this is a lopsided
match so far there's no other way around
it this is when commentators started
inventing other things to talk about so
Eric do you have any PG jokes or is that
not something just bras have in their
repertoire yeah that's one of the
weaknesses one of one of the weaknesses
of the chest part for all repertoire is
PG jokes yes
did you hear my story yesterday on
amateur hour about when me and Ralph's
mom met off and on Dracon went when
searching for spirits in Lubbock Texas
when it was still a dry County no no I
missed it it was a fun story
I was busy on the airplane flying in
they had to have a chat system now on
the thing where you can put in your seat
number and try to invite other people
into a private chat room and there was a
big message that says in the beginning
that you can't solicit for certain
activities but I was inviting I was
trying to get people into a chat room
and trying to cause a bit of a ruckus
and only AM on join me in the private
room oh man classic it doesn't count
when it's basically your brother right I
mean yeah exactly your brother with a
beard haven't checked on our social
contest yet doing any photo shops of
hair crazy hair on me or Eric or show us
your craziest hairdo to talk about
Magnus's phase he went through but it
seemed like a good phase for Magnus cuz
right it right after post post crazy
hair Eric he ended up with his his new
girlfriend and it seems that seems that
Magnus is chess is on track for the
remainder of 2017 ya know I found you
know you can tell you can generally tell
if a guy is single or not maybe based on
his hairstyle is that are you are you
giving any hints there I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a little hashtag speech yes
search hashtag speech just search let's
see if we're getting any and don't know
if we're oh look at that we are getting
some crazy hair Photoshop challenges
that is the ugliest picture of my hair
I've ever seen Eric I think there's some
that you're really gonna like though I
think I think you should consider I had
a very edgy haircut at the 2014 Olympiad
in Norway yeah that got a lot of
feedback but I'm not sure if anybody
made it it was yeah
a lot of comments some good ones here
not okay Wow if this guy had a real
haircut this might actually be winning
the diamond membership the green gecko
mohawk that's that's pretty awesome it
looks like we've got a few submissions
so far remember everybody a one-year
Diamond membership on the line I also
like the afro to Magnus Carl
by at 96 Juan Jose Jose GA on Twitter
that's a it's one of my favorites so far
so anyway remind everybody do a hair
challenge remind Magnus of what he's
missing lacking his crazy hair and Eric
and I will go back to uh to the chess960
game right now so what's going on in
this position Eric I know it's like I
feel like I'm being the worst co-host
well Eric what's going on with the chess
I don't even have time for this I got a
weird position and that's what he needs
to do yeah he was forced to do it cuz
it's just I'm 60 and as I said I think
she has the best chances Black has two
minors for the rook that being Magnus
but he is lacking some development so
yeah I was just going to say though if
Kadir can get going here on the open
files you might see a victory here right
doc needs to plug the position the dere
needs to stop them from doing that what
I see is Brooke c1 is a nice move
because Bach maybe want to play Bishop
c5 Bishop Keyes's
and sort of manually protect his king so
this this this is looking well it's
dangerous however one issues the Knights
have such good squares that on c7 looks
weird well then I don't have six can go
to d5 minutes an outpost that protects
and it protects everything in fact in
that position the Knights to protect the
pause the pawns protect the Knights it's
a big happy family so yeah it's starting
to my initial instincts coming back
after our social media check-in we're oh
good ears got an initiative the more I
look at it I feel like Magnus is just a
mover to from consolidating and then
he's gonna get back to good
old-fashioned family fun 495 threatening
Queen a checkmate Magnus quickly stops
that if Knight f7 rook F ain't covers it
the tactics are not working in through
my butt you threaten me that was the
first time you started mate Danny hey
you know what they say it's the attempt
that counts at least that's what I mean
they invented a stat for people like me
losers that you know like the stat
attempts on goal isn't that a stat for
literally failures like shots on goal
mm-hmm I feel like the Canadians
invented that stat is that a fair thing
does the countries know real general
though No
but the other thing we don't score much
you know I was just kidding relax all
right relax no I but I mean it is a
hockey stat and didn't Canadians invent
hockey shots on goal is a hockey stat so
I'm not trying to put you on the spot
here buddy but don't they have that in
in soccer as well and I mean it's the
same I mean I don't know but essentially
the the stat is for failing it's not for
scoring it's for failing to score I
agree I mean Danny I grew up a Kobe fan
so I had to deal with a lot of stats
like that or percentages right some of
those days when he would shoot 50 50 50
balls I would go Kobe fan is there
anything you want to talk about are you
doing okay with that I'm still I'm still
still Kobe found I didn't deal with a
lot of flock with without statistic yeah
okay all right all right Queen age three
h6 Magnus's maneuver but gideros now
poking at both sides of the board this
is a good strategy right keeping black
off balance this is a good strategy this
isn't imbalance and this is this is uh
you know I would say the position is
unclear anyways because buck-buck can't
consolidate yet with so many pieces on
the board so I mean this is sort of
positioning he wants to be in Queen D
for maybe now yeah I was gonna say is
you looking for ideas like rook b8 check
to work yeah I feel like why doesn't
move away from a winning tactic here
right well it's to Queen d4 centralize
the Queen and make sure it doesn't get
kicked out and I mean I don't see what
it really does on h4 it's it's that King
on Queenie for King e7r fp6 ideas it's
not working yet but it's getting there
do you know what I mean this relates
back to our shots on goal thing which
someone on my team just came to your
rescue and said technically even if you
score it's considered a shot on goal so
anyway the the tactics I'm looking for
in the analysis board something where
you can capture on f8 and then like took
a minute to do that move I mean come on
you got your your knight is good you
look
your work on Siwon is good your King
can't do anything your queen needs to
improve it's the best piece it has to be
at its maximum for you to have a
successful attack you took way too much
time and finding the only hope they're
agreed 100% and that's that if that
comes down to again a time pressure
issue then you know okay you have to you
have to play the logical moves fast
that's one thing you have to do in blitz
so the good thing here is why now is
potential for connected means are
connected passed pawns some end games
might be favorable for him now the
magnet is consolidated his king he's
he's flipping the script he wants to go
get an attack and so good dear good your
advice to those pawns are slow I like
two blocks position 94 then I can go to
D - there's tactics on the f2 pawn this
those are tricky Knights and very strong
guys 95 maybe even getting around being
playing f3 maybe 9 HP check but those
are clumsy bonds and great Knights yep
great Knights and white can't push both
pawns because the knight on d5 keeps the
me - pawn back oh wow g5 here King d6
Magnus is having fun here again ok 5
very nice he puts the clamp on any Queen
side progress for now no beep oh good
dear sacrificing as a tactic rook to c4
will come in the end everybody after
Knight takes rook c4 is gonna fork the
ponies
yeah those that's looks like it's
working
that's a problem and maybe Magnus missed
that he did he did and the only issue is
is still really ok so B 5 and a 5 are
coming quickly that's that's fair so 96
okay that's a big turnaround right there
right I mean you know it is change the
game for white these pawns you had the
exact same position a minute ago but the
Paul was on b2 the issue I see here for
widest block once the player k5 a
1994-95 work you just blended the game
Dani right there and he goes nice and
good here
Kadir is gonna take a break everyone's
gonna take a break we're gonna let
Magnus know he can take a break
anyone who wants to can take a break
even the fans at home I give you
permission to take a break and go get
some popcorn but not until after we we
you and I take a quick moment to gather
ourselves wow we just saw the biggest
lopsided time control and speeches
championship history Eric how does that
make you feel well I'd like to I mean
are you gonna thank me at this time or
Thank You economy yeah I'm kidding
do you know the story that we got almost
arrested at the academy no I was I was
making an Academy Awards reference to it
a little bit back left you're pulling us
we okay scoot back to my last no they
thought Amon planted his beard hairs in
a dish at the restaurant called the
Academy in Montreal and they called the
police on they thought we were trying to
get a free meal by planting a hair in
the food and they specifically thought
there was a mana and the police came and
no I thought you didn't know about the
society first of all if I knew about it
I would have happily trolled you so
let's not pretend I'm better than that
but I actually didn't know about that
it's just coincidence
I'm on street and you know that beard
he's not getting the preferential
treatment no I mean people are even
calling him a hobo on Twitter I mean we
need to get this guy a GM title stat
right I mean ASAP so the police on us
Danny I mean like I was always live to
say you know it's I know we did sounds
like discrimination it is discrimination
and we got everyone to post on Yelp but
they took took away the bad reduce oh
yeah yeah well it's called the Academy I
do want to make it clear the Academy
here in Montreal people are well they're
you know the the Academy needs to not
discriminate against beards we don't
discriminate against sponsors for chess
me or Eric we're gonna talk a little bit
about the Masterclass sponsorship that
the speech Chess Championship has so let
me ask you something I asked him on what
would you appreciate learning from Garry
Kasparov if you were to watch this
master class even as an advanced
obviously very strong Grandmaster
you know he's the greatest world
champion of all time still by most
people's account and he's got this
course from master class coming out what
would you like to learn from the the one
and only Garry Kasparov I mean
his approach the chest the amount of
work he put in is still almost
unparalleled from from all the stories
I've heard but his handling of dynamic
positions is his energy I mean just the
way he plays and he's I would I mean
anything and everything like I he when I
first started playing chess that was
around the time he pretty much stopped
so he's still modern enough that I I was
very interested in he's still very sharp
so what I hear there is advance there is
stuff for advanced players of course
everyone's curious what secret opening
novelties he said he was going to reveal
that he never used but the majority of
his of his series is is for the sort of
aspiring to be stronger tournament
player 1300 to 1500 which is a big part
of our audience here so if you had any
questions about whether you should you
definitely to go to masterclass comm
slash chess garry kasparov diving into
everything that made him a great world
champion in revealing some secrets along
the way Kadir who say enough is gonna
have to reveal some secrets in the back
half of this event today Eric we are
looking at an 8 to 1 score magnus
carlsen is putting on a show I'm gonna
have to start thinking of more more side
topics to talk about and keep you in the
PG realm cuz I know what I know where
you go when your mind starts to wander
I've been there with you so so we're all
hoping for a closer match as this moves
on is that right for sure but the
momentum and the history this is the
second year you guys are doing this
doesn't favor the lower rated player at
all well both players are now back in
their in their seats as we as we switch
over here to the to the camera view
Magnus put on a hoodie
Kadir looks like he he switched his he
switched beverages so easy maybe switch
to something a little stronger and and
we're back on the road here the
three-minute portion has begun and and
here we go Eric we're mixing things up
at least this is an opening we haven't
seen yet so far
oh you seen the fear in cattle bishop
well right but not not this approach
from Magnus I mean ya know okay well
he's still snacking away how much how
much food can one person eat in the
middle of a show this isn't you know I
don't know what he thinks this is but
maybe he's trying to get a sponsor of a
snack on on camera and I'm and I'm not
picking up the hint I alright well it's
eight to one I mean honestly
Kadir has to figure this out we're all
rooting for a victory for the underdog
for him to get something going here
we've got a dynamic game right now black
has the early established f5 and if he
gets his way maybe he'll get a king set
attack but something tells me Magnus is
gonna be just fine when you have a
feeling kid or bishop you normally don't
get checkmated by a pawn storm late
least not like this kind of pawn storm
no I mean the English is a bit safer
than some of the mainline Kings Kings
Indian lines for white I mean you don't
get as much but you don't risk as much
either right bit more conservative
all right well remind the fans you can
interact with us on speed chess as this
match goes on if it remains a lopsided
victory maybe Eric and I will have a
little more time to engage with the
twitch chat you know how Eric feels
about gauging with the the I've been
reading the the chat the entire stream
but there are a lot of lot of guys after
me yeah I assume I assume they're there
guys I'm hoping that I'm still in the
green or in the good crab at the female
gears but there are a lot of people just
just just making fun of me and I hunt
taking it on the chin I love it I love
it you know what they they make fun of
me regularly to I mean I'm not trying to
I I think I think it's a
passive-aggressive approach than they
see it is it is I I have noticed that
that there's a lot of insulting comments
but if I ever but then if I read the
comment and they know they got attention
they're like yeah right so that's kind
of how it works
all right Magnus is he's taking care of
the palm storm but d3 is now a problem I
don't know unless he unless he's gonna
punch d4 through maybe he punches d4
open well d4 runs into 94 okay I think
and you don't want to give up your life
script bishop okay so d4 would have run
into 94 we would have had a problem with
all kinds of relationships yeah for me
Danny I wasn't surprised by this because
Magnus recently put a beating on me I
played him over the board for the first
time for some fun games back in Olive
man and you know I knew what was coming
yeah I think I think I was an appetizer
for him a warm-up nice little you said
you guys hooked up for a little blitz
affair it was an affair I wouldn't I'm
not sure I don't like to put labels
right but it was it was open and it was
everybody was consensual in that
situation obviously it was a consensual
affair yeah yeah oh okay well you know
I've also been a part of one of those
with Magnus lucky even lowly little I am
me at a special event he made the
mistake of of letting me draw the first
game or let's say I made the mistake and
like he literally shifted in his chair
and I think I blacked out the rest of it
was so abusive that I just I don't even
met he beat me to one over and over and
over again and it was it was crazy but
the first game I like I have played him
and it was up itani he I should have won
and he barely true and then after that
he just it was like III had poked the
bear so um anyway
hüseyin up let's do a lot more I mean
Magnus is like I mean I think he's
exceptional in that case you beat him if
he loses an attorney mcgamer in a blitz
game he just gets stronger I think him
and he karu are really really good at
that I love about these matches we hold
Eric I mean seriously like it's so fun
to see these guys you see Magnus is just
what does that evening now spaghetti I
mean well I think most chess fans you
know they see these guys in tournament
you don't ever get this kind of up close
and personal view of them and their life
I mean Magnus is a superstar I mean he's
you know you know people want to know
what he looks like when he eats well now
we know apparently he likes noodles and
he didn't even do like the appropriate
thing where you like cut the noodles in
twirl it so you don't slurp it up he's
slurping up his noodles right now no mm
I never eat on stream
and for first date I never go for food
it's always for drinks because itself
calling you know I've been shy about
eating showing my own culture the eating
routine habits yeah I don't have that
problem buddy I think my wife and I wish
we still had a little more mystery but
let's not digress into that I will say
this Magnus Carlsen is eight to one
victory in the first portion if you're
just joining us Magnus Carlsen putting
on a show is the biggest ever strangely
we're now in the three-minute but as
Mike climb pointed out the largest
three-minute victory ever was actually
by Nakamura over MBL I mean being that
his opponent is maxing vache the grove
you wouldn't expect that but last year
in last year's championship I had met
Nakamura took down Maxime by a 7-game
difference so if I if Carlsen really
wants to break all records including
Hikaru's he needs to be COO CN off my
seven games were more in this
three-minute portion he's in a tough
spot here Dani King g7 Bishop c5 are
being threatened upon on c6 is amazing
because it really that Bishop would be
ideally placed on d5 yeah how do you
stop Bishop c5 and recap to see King g1
king king g1 King G seven bishops if I
was coming and yeah and black gets a bit
of the initiative so it's gotta be a bit
careful here no and there's even ideas
like there's even ideas like H for
coming to pry open dark squares at some
point but I do love King g7 followed by
Bishop c5 and maybe white just has to
run the rook back from a1 to f1 but that
feels totally passed and you're sort of
in the permanent thing yeah like I mean
so King g7 okay
I found a way to get the Queen's off the
board or no he didn't so what would have
happened there well Magnus is still
ambitious that's that's I think what's
happening here he wants to put his king
on g2 force blocks to play Bishop d6
here although Bishop d6 isn't
necessarily the threads I mean so maybe
didn't take me five you're saying Magus
didn't take you five not because he
thinks he's losing but because he he
thinks that he would just have rather so
he still wants to do it he wants the win
he wants to put his plan is working on G
to target the g6 phone targeting e5 pawn
and stabilized but one thing we can
already see in the time is that both
players are under a minute
that's one of the big differences
everything from here on out only gets
faster and more furious hashtag first
Vin Diesel reference of the day so we've
got King g2 coming here and then I think
white will actually I still don't see
how white is gonna make progress here I
mean every piece is pinned down to this
to this weakness on f2
he's about yeah he may not be able to
make progress maybe I want to play h4
just to fix the pawns okay you did this
move instead what's the ideas of what is
it what is the idea if he takes it he's
gone before he's gonna go for the attack
ah he's going for the attack because he
sees he's down to 20 seconds he's taking
some risk where I like it Danny good for
ants
maybe now what would be a no it might be
slow what's the follow-up Bishop c5 is
coming anyways and the king is safe on
the dark squares yes ago King g2 and me
Bishop c5 nobody can't push the F on
because the Queen goes in the back door
that's crazy one and that's mate I liked
it but it also might be undoing here
yeah you might end up going down for the
first time because he wanted to win so
badly
Bishop f3 yeah no he just lost upon
their dannion well perhaps he realized
appropriately that he really he can
really can't lose this still right I
mean yes maybe I'll try very well might
might win this but yeah he's he's
counting on his defensive resources to
be a bishop f3 now Bishop c5 Queen f3
check can you get to the g6 pawn I don't
see it well I don't think I can and
black has b5 coming at some point we're
gonna get a Queen side passed pawn
bishop takes g6 maybe our Queen takes f2
and not just liquidates into a yeah man
good
okay well goosey enough goes for b5 this
is his only chance to win now he's gonna
play Queen takes f2 he's got two right
yeah yeah and the transition into the
endgame is gonna be the third draw of
the day yeah yeah look at that nice
little sacrifice gives us an educational
moment remember everybody as long as the
bishop is the wrong color corner you can
draw those games even if you're down a
piece so the King gets into the black
square corner and it's just a draw so
all right Eric well at least you say
enough isn't he hasn't lost yet in the
three-minute portion so he's got to be
feeling good about that
and for sure I mean we can see that
based on their blitz ratings he's
actually not doing badly right like
maybe ice is not operating in the match
and so it's just just being a huge
underdog and that's that's simply the
situation here
well Magnus mixing it up now goes for
this sort of obscure g6
Lopez white immediately challenges with
d4 this is one of the sharper ways you
can play against the g6 Lopez everybody
so we'll see if GU say enough is advise
taking Eric's advice and he's gonna be a
little more aggressive here in the
three-minute portion he needs to he's
going for it I mean in some ways it's a
positional line you play f3 you're like
[ __ ] as double bonds Bishop on g4
doesn't have like a juicy diagonal once
I get our three in and yeah and still
play it so it's actually not gonna be a
sharp position it's gonna be a bit like
a Roy Lopez exchange end okay and still
I mean White's totally fine but I'm not
sure this will turn into I'm not sure
that he chose the right move order to
make it exciting he's up on time right
now it still has more time than he
started the game with although you know
I have a question Danny you're in this
situation or you're you're down eight
and a half one and a half do you you
know you're making draws and you can be
confident maybe that you'll make a few
more draws do you'll be like okay I'm
probably gonna lose this match let's try
to score you know stabilize get a few
points on the board or do you still have
the idea let's go for a win I really
wanna be Magnus Carlsen I don't mind
losing more games to provide myself a
chance at a victory right but at the
same time you know the Internet's gonna
sort of crucify you you lose like twenty
to one and a half so what we know you
have the guts to never give up a little
lopsided you go for more no matter what
and that's led to some some of the best
content on the internet you're the
famous Nakamura battles but you know I I
think I'm probably more along your lines
and just you know not nearly as strong
as you but I think I love to win enough
that I'm willing to risk it to continue
to push but I understand you know the
strategy of buckling up and and sitting
tight a little bit you know I don't know
I think in a match like this the money
isn't that big of a deal if you're gonna
lose
the match you know you're coming up on
the short side of things every game is
worth a few dollars here and there
everybody if you if you need a reminder
the the format does have it so that the
the prize fund is split by win
percentage as you can see here so there
is something on the line even when
you're gonna lose the match but but
overall I think I subscribe to your
theory Eric you got to be aggressive go
for the win I can simplify it and I
think I'm gonna persuade a lot of people
in the crowd would you take three draws
against Magnus one and a half points or
a win and I think I'm not gonna be
playing - regularly that win is a good
story right it's a good scalp
I'll take oh it's even worthless I'll
take that win over three draws right
yeah yeah so they have a point I mean it
should be by all like measures of like
sporting you would say well I have 200
points or the truth is no you got to get
the victory against Magnus I agree
I want the victory that's going to
impress impress your grandkids one day
yep I don't know I don't know that it
would impress my grandkids but yeah well
that's because you have so many other
accomplishments yeah right we'll play
but the my kids don't play chess I can't
get him to play chess and I you know
they're going a different direction it's
rebellion from dad you know it's uh it's
just rebellion issues but anyway Goosen
off has he is better here I mean this
this does look like a a good rule of
physics changing the reason I say that
is because white has the majority in
these positions everybody the
three-on-two and he's done a pretty good
job advancing them is it gonna be enough
I mean I don't know but I think that I
think the whites a little better here
mmhmm yeah if he can it be great to
trade off pieces then you're sort of
using that majority freely right now
block you know can maybe block put a net
on e5 put a knight on d4 no I'm tactics
so yeah you do want to restrict some of
blacks counter play and if you can get
into that endgame but is the plus of
this line is yeah leverage that the
potential postpone into it's very very
favorable so he's not he's not worried
about this Knight coming to e5 why is
that I I think you're totally right that
if black can establish this knight on e5
and start blockading the dark square
the problems on 85 here after 95 attempt
oh then I'm gonna take on e5 and try to
just get the Queen's off okay so this
this would have been his approach here
something like this to have the better
in game all right that makes sense so so
here if King c1 maybe then Knight d4
black is getting that D file Cantor play
that he needs to overcome the three onto
majority but I I agree with you Danny
that I like white I don't like this time
management in what is a fairly static
position yeah yeah and it's tough right
I mean you want to be accurate but I
think that's one thing that the more
experienced blitz players do and you
always see Nakamura and Carlsen almost
always up on time here because you know
I mean look at right Carlsen even Blount
has made a few big blunders but in the
match but he's still gone on to do to go
do well in those games cuz because time
has been so important he seems to be
quite happy they're quite smiling
talking I can't tell sometimes if he's
chewing or talking or why not but yeah I
wish I wish I was that relaxed not
platelets yeah no he's totally relaxed
well it's easy to be relaxed when you're
up eight to one you know you're like
you're like stressed against the wall
because you're always taking on the
toughest challenge yeah yeah you know
you should do that every once in a while
maybe take on somebody that you can beat
up eight to one well that's the chess
brush oh that's so that's how I try to
regain self-esteem you regain all the
confidence you get the mojo going again
mm-hmm yeah okay well now Magnus found a
way to get in the back door and this is
this is about to get gruesome Queen to
see fries Midway 992 yeah I've seen this
factor stuff before and it's not gonna
end well the section north but it is a
bit of a mating pattern yeah Queen good
to see one oh this is I think a deer
just missed that so you can give a check
you can give a check and play a 91 check
and I do want that right now nine to be
one but Magnus is is gonna go back to d4
with the knight now the queen is cut off
in C twos week now 94 and there's there
is game over so there's night before
technically there's night before here to
prolong it but he just needs to find one
moving this is this is over what is that
gonna I wonder if you can even just move
the bishop from a six to e2 and threaten
a five Eric
I like that Danny what I move a bit
should be too hard to play see three aha
yeah that'll save okay so he does the
same idea and I think the deer will find
will find c3 but oh if c3 there was
Bishop d3 that would have been so good -
yeah no this is this is look at the time
though zero to a minute and a half yes
it's just this is just too much this is
almost like watching myself as you heard
but it's even worse with a minute and a
half to like like it's it's it's
frustrating and I can say you know
heading into the match both players were
very professional this morning online
early hanging out with Magnus and his
pj's Kadir gets online Kadir was
actually chatting with me privately
while him and magnus from the same thing
just saying how like how nervous he is
and how he just like doesn't expect
today's gonna go well so full disclosure
Kadir kind of saw this one coming today
and you know he's he's obviously
fighting his best but this is just a
tough tough matchup for him so yeah
Magnus is leaning in eating spaghetti
enjoying the actually eating spaghetti
though no he is no I've already seen the
noodles go in yeah yeah no if you see
the noodle go in then that's if you see
that it'll go in then you get
confirmation so yeah that's the confirm
some 43 minutes left in the three-minute
portion and no but it's the sharp
positions even that last game I think
there needed to be more urgency he let
Magnus essentially like it wasn't Magnus
got the initiative again he just he just
um
right I don't know something in the
middle game he's he's not not going for
that well yeah I mean he needs he needs
to play sharper positions purely from
the perspective of you have better
chance of and of inducing a blunder even
if it is against Magnus but again I
think I think it's something you
highlighted the beginning of the show
today you were you were prophetic in
your prediction that he is a limited
repertoire and he's he's kind of a trick
manoeuvring guy but you know who do you
think of when you think of the best
tricky maneuver or you know on the
planet right and I think um
like like you said it's just tough for a
deer to mix it up like you would want to
when you know it's hard hard to find
weaknesses here against Carlson so we
have 42 minutes Eric the son looks like
it's starting to go a little lower for
you on the East Coast there you change
your lighting actually I've three broken
light bulbs the only one working one
this is the state of affairs here yeah
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be yes so I'm
gonna be I'm gonna how many grandmasters
does it take to screw light bulb is
literally you have enough and the house
it mined out and I I don't know how to
do it but there's only one working light
bulb I just figured to be better people
see less of me and usually that's this
is amazing right here if this is I have
to point this out if Knight a5 is played
here this is the exact same tactic that
we had on the board for John Herschel in
the amateur hours ago but there's no 97
then I can do 968 no I note that that
was the tactic or she'll had to find in
fact he failed he had to find that it
didn't work and he actually failed to do
it but if anybody who watches the
amateur hour on chefs TV with John
Herschel this was the exact same tactic
we're in this position he failed to
realize white it was forced to take a
perpetual on Knight a5 anyway just that
that was like that's like amazing that
that even occurred here I mean that
literally was last week's show that's
hilarious
all right well uh rookie one if 95 is
played by Kadir then Magnus can can take
a perpetual with night of seven Magnus
taking a perpetual no way yeah get dere
wants more though qadir wants uh I think
a dear feels like he's a little better
here maybe taking advantage of some of
the awkwardness he has the F file the
III Bishop is a target
I mean after Knight a5 I can just like
Queen named for and Sun my queen age 4
and your night on a5
might be a bit in this place so it
wasn't a forced repetition right okay
well here comes Knight f7 and good dear
ready to stack the exchange in order to
get an initiative on the F file you
simply blundered that I think Danny
because this is just worse than before
like now the Queen's are being
threatened trade it off and what attack
is there yeah your your pieces are but
maybe Bishop before in the night in I'm
not sure but I think that was a blunder
yeah the more you look at it I mean if
there was no way to get the initiative
with the Queen still in here there's no
way black feels like his pressure is any
better
and now if the F file is is no longer
under blacks control then again we're on
the road we're on the Magna strain right
now we're just all were all victims here
were handcuffed Magnus is the driver
he's gonna take us wherever he wants to
take us here yeah okay you're black
you're done in exchange you're down 30
seconds he's gonna first of all I want
to make this my kingdom a plain age 67
secondly I want to put mine at about
five I think oh I thought Magnus might
play Age 3 to try to get the bishop off
of the D file I need betters squares
from a piece and I don't see six not
doing anything why hasn't black buddy
for like a long time ago to free up that
e5 square I don't know but it's weird
here because nice move nicely move book
do you want that's why dismissal with
the best of them everybody if you take
the Queen this is a transition that's
easily winning for white and if you
don't take the Queen you're forced to
play a move like Queen c8 which just
passive so I mean it looks like he's
just the Messiah he's wrong here now
this is ninety six is coming he's
resigned to his fate here but he could
have put up way more resistance he's no
it's uh we should try to make this
harder for Magnus somehow we can start
spamming him and chat just kidding this
is just Magnus's he's rolling I mean
look at that very accurate yeah no very
accurate I'm just seeing a difference
here I mean that Bishop on g7 is bad he
had a lot of time to try to improve that
earlier on when he was up upon yep
there's no sense of urgency there and
he's often leaving himself with I don't
know misplaced pieces well I think
psychologically you know I mean we've
talked about that in this format he
get down like this and it's just so hard
to see the light at the end of the
tunnel right especially when in a
tournament game you have so much more
opportunities to gather yourself
emotionally I think a deer is just he's
just frustrated not to say that Magnus
isn't the heavy favorite right but I
mean you're right he's not he's not
playing as well as he probably even
would have if he wasn't down nine to one
against against the world champion so
Magnus now choosing whether he wants to
take he ate and then meat night take c3
with rook a 1 or if he wants to play
move like Bishop g5 I think and grab the
diagonal which probably still forces
black to lose 85 looks like a good move
I like Bishop e5 a little better but I
think I think both 98 and Bishop c5 are
probably good enough okay let's go back
to some analysis here the point
everybody with Bishop c5 is that it
guards e7 so it still prevents black
from finding a safe Square for the rook
and Magnus indeed goes for it so if the
rook can't go here that means any other
square loses the bishop so that's why
Eric and I were liking Bishop c5 and and
Magnus does it 36 minutes in the
three-minute portion the wheels have
come off raggedy right now right now
we're hoped were we're begging for mercy
which is an absolutely horrible song by
Shawn Mendes please tell me that Shawn
Mendes is not on the chest bra playlist
thank you that was the right answer to
that question I don't I would admit if I
knew it was I've no idea he's Canadian I
think I think you should know just as
like you're being you're yeah Google
that Shawn Mendes he's uh yes I somehow
I knew he was Canadian don't ask me how
I think it's just the way he sings and
in a whiny way kind of like Justin
Bieber but um no Shawn Mendes is the
latest like male pop person every shot
song sounds the same my kids listen to
it and I want to I want to scratch my
ears off so I think you brought up some
Mendes and we're in Arizona and you and
I also didn't know that did I really
yeah well what happened in Arizona that
we don't remember and it about your kids
listening yeah we forgot a lot of things
this is one of the few but yeah I rant
about my kids often you know that's what
happens when they drive you crazy oh
okay good dear made a move there with
0.3 seconds getting time back on the
clock he actually has this interesting
little pass beep on it this is kind of
an irritating position for white well
yeah I just took Goodyear losing
position and no time to come up with
that which is the problem yeah but I
like that burst of energy we just saw
yeah pushing some pawns playing actively
all these generating threats and I mean
we just haven't seen that today oh man
but now now the threats you know it's a
yeah sorry what is your place when we're
slowly you should have someone throw you
know somebody will yell at us from the
other room play faster right right well
always have a bunch of guys we need a
chest garage to run for in from the
other room and go Stone Cold Steve
Austin and just spirit a :
that's a cockle home or croc a cold one
yeah no I mean that would have been that
would be appropriate right now it's it's
hard right he's got kids in the other
room so he can't have those guys they
were getting rowdy and keeping the
energy high but job yeah you've been
roasting me Johnny but see Magnus is not
showing you so d it's a swag I've seen
him wear that before I actually offered
him a chest bro hoodie he didn't take it
he didn't he didn't take it
no he didn't take it and he's got better
better clothing so yeah yeah I've been
getting used to rejection yes though
I've seen those chests Brodie's I want
one those things are not very comfy they
look super comfortable honestly ya know
that if are those available to fans um
special ones right now okay if not you
need to make them available I bet you
guys would sell a lot of those I mean
that's we know it's happening it's
happening is the top form we're working
on we're cool you got Robin is studying
finance and he's working on on it as a
project I love it
alright well do scene of his once again
a little better but he needs to so he
started out up on time a lot what is the
psychology of that right he starts out
up on time and then as soon as the
critical tactics start to occur he slow
well he slowly gets slower but this is a
great position for white he's got a
great position in the follow-up
h4g for could need to push pawns right
there's more pieces on the board this is
your best chance serious the h4 is very
normal
g4 is normal but like don't be so
reactive to what Magnus is doing right
yeah and I don't even buy this move c5
so what if he just takes d6 what's the
line what if he takes d6 he's gonna play
is it so Magnus is just giving up the
pawn you're saying yes at the end of
these lines 96 96 and 84 that's
something to expect 96 okay okay he's
sacrificing the pond and trading off all
the pieces so oh whoa a little tempo in
the dark squares everybody I didn't like
I'm like caching caching out because it
sort of makes blacks position so much
easier play but yeah if they go for this
force line black picks up the bishop a
check and grabs d4 and I think that's
what we're about to see maybe he'll take
on d4 with the pawn I'm not sure yeah he
does that
this is not I just had a huge space
advantage now I just lost we trade off
of some pawns move Arizona 12 his
decision-making has been off in critical
moments where the he's not making -
uncomfortable at all it's very hard to
make comfortable but coming at him or
maybe some specific opening you know
you're gone back to move 12 and you're
totally right 90 to e4 feels natural but
it's the move that actually allowed c5
because it took away the pin on the
bishop I said exactly good right if he
had played h4 just gone all-in over here
it's actually very hard for Magnus to
push anything everybody because you've
got this you've got this pin it's
amazing though I mean seriously like you
get you give Magnus credit - right I
mean 94 felt natural
and suddenly c5 and everything has
changed
yeah and so you're right I mean h4 was
what's more accurate but it dumb I was
still feeling like white was in the
driver's seat 94 and just sort of
surprised by how easily Magnus sort of
weaseled his way out of them Magnus is
back over 3,000 by the way so if that's
not a trend in the wrong direction for
Agadir I don't know what is he's back
over 3,000 my question is how do you
extract that night from b7 Magnus you
know what Magnus is gonna make
embarrassing players by the game
finishes and your pieces are all
misplaced right a few games in I'll man
I think Eliana and Caruana
yeah yeah just the opponent's just
resigned because my pieces are so bad no
you're killing it right that Eliana of
game was like a clinic as soon as he
played C takes b5 in Magnus just grabbed
the C file and opened and gobbled up the
pawns like what is that night on b7 -
how does that ever come up you have to
like joint effort to get it to d6 and
right for whereas due to the effort it
takes it takes a village to save that
knife we've we've got some problems here
well the Energy's high Danny the
viewership is picking up where we've
just overtaken Minecraft on on Twitch
let's--can clan tag you know what is
anybody else sick of Minecraft being a
head on twitch a head of chess on twitch
can you guys help us with that go tell
your friends let's boost some viewership
here
agreed what number are we right now on
Twitch 14 I think let's do it let's get
to the top ten come on even with the
landslide we know Carlson is gonna be
taking on Wesley so in round two and by
the way in round two we already have the
dates I want to mention this right now
Maxime vache LaGravenese ander Grichuk
which I am so excited for that match by
the way grishnack and the L I can't even
wait for that I mean Grichuk MVL is
taking place on October what is it I
believe 24th 25th I need I need some
updates here from my teammates um
Nakamura Caruana the Battle of the
Americans we didn't even mean for that
to happen Eric it just worked out with
the seating Nakamura Caruana is going
down November 2nd okay yeah that's
awesome right
I'm actually gonna ask my teammates who
I know we're listening remind me of the
exact dates of the the nepo that we got
Russian on Russian action and we got
American on American action then we've
got Sasha and Maxine and then we got
Wesley cell and Carlson we know that
that's so Carlson matchup is gonna have
is gonna break its gonna break twitch
but let's let's get some higher
viewership today everybody
I think restruck MBL is as you said
marquee matchup to talk about players
ESP dress yeah grishnack lvl is gonna be
crazy but I'm trying to Bieber mighty
you can just go to speech Chess
Championship calm by the way everybody
if you don't want to wait for my for my
brain and the fact that I've forgotten
when the next round is but well the game
is revolving around the night on b7 I
sort of expected because it's the
sticking out like a sore thumb
yeah those nights don't have outposts
they're in the wrong side of town and
Magnus is gonna take advantage of them
is there a wrong side of the town for
the chest bras is that a thing or is you
guys you guys own all of town kind of is
pretty safe okay okay and I'm modest
from the roughest town in Canada anyways
which it makes sense he looks like that
yeah okay so MBL Grichuk is October 23rd
mark your calendars October 23rd then
Sergey Karjakin takes on yonder palm
Neha XI October 26th Hikaru Nakamura and
Fabiano Caruana
on November 2nd and Magnus Carlsen I'm
gonna go ahead and say it I'm gonna
assume he's not gonna lose today we'll
be taking on Wesley so November 21st so
again the order will be all matches
before Magnus Carlsen plays in November
21st but after that you literally need
to like make sure your whole December's
plan because the the semifinals and the
finals are will be played very very
quickly after that so the next few
months are gonna be dominated by speech
Chess Championship matches on the web
and right before that October 24th date
I'll be seeing you Danny that's right at
some underground law some underground
matches that's what's fun should be a
lot we got it we'll get we'll get the
camera out and well we said we were
gonna do that too Sanh and we did but
then you you wouldn't know who was on
your team again you had John on your
team you guys were just crushing us and
even want any part of that
what did you do remember we played the
tiendas blitz oh yeah yeah yeah it was
me in Bartholomew I had I had narrowed
iski on my team but Dillon yeah I mean
I'm not gonna lie
Don yeah you know I mean okay ed let's
be honest I was the weak link but but
alright so Magnus is really mixing it up
now he's showing us the full playlist
busting out of London 84 yeah we got 84
92 or 93 Bishop age to the usual moves
easier to play he's gonna let him get a
5 I love a 5 this is just for black no
it's not good for black at all you're
not gonna know positionally this is the
technical term here everybody is less
than ideal this is not what you this is
the president you really you know he's
got a play game without putting that
Bishop on g7 just try it once right
anyway you know what they say once you
fee and keto you never go back
so that's kind of what it where he's at
right now gideros he's you know he is a
bit of a creature of habit that's ok I
mean obviously over the board when
you're prepared it's a little bit harder
to be sort of smashed consistently like
this but this is just it's it's tough
it's tough for us and not to you know
we're not the victims here obviously
we're what we're watching a massacre and
good dears the victim but it's tough to
watch when the player is really getting
outplayed but not really making any
efforts to kind of mix it up a little
bit so it's just it's just tough for a
good ear right now but look it was a
good move because otherwise I was just
gonna have a field day double on the F
I'll take advantage of that a7 weakness
yeah this would be five you're
questioning the net on 85 are you gonna
get back maybe I'll play c4 at some
moment baby I'll know but that's a good
point yeah you've got this e4 square
maybe as you said maybe you play c4 but
even if you don't you've made that
knights knife a little light nice light
a little difficult yep so what do you do
for your white here let's continue to
try to learn from this even if we know
it's a laid-off straight off just go
forward to result game which is sort of
being the trend he hasn't been just like
just no bad position so so trade off say
that is
the weakness I mean c4 could be played
right now the issue is the Knights not
gonna ever be trapped why can double on
the a file and at some point break on
the B file because the vision one f4
nicely covers that the eight squared
which is where black would like plays
the rook no that's key it just prevents
all kinds of counter play over there
black black kind of wants a five at some
point right but it's it's risky those
hanging pawns but that's partly why I
played rook da right cuz he wants to get
e5 I like I mean based on the match and
everything yes you do need to do things
like that lady five do it but you should
do it without thinking I agree with you
without thinking he five and the point
everybody as Eric was saying which is
true when the D file opens you are
dealing with positional weaknesses here
but you know you need an open dynamic
opportunity here and the whole purpose
of rook e8 is to guard the D pawn so
that you can get away with opening the
position okay place c4 first but I oh
yeah I don't like c4 I feel like yeah I
like b3 a lot after takes everybody
Magnus is just sacking to reopen the
position and get counter play on the B
file and Qadir might miss his chance to
get the e5 again
I like b3 b3 b1 he's gonna make this
who's gonna get the initiative very
quickly here we have a b-1 i now he did
he file but just to e5 first hanging
pawns yeah it more uncomfortable for
Magus to deal with in this because now
white also has the e-file at his
disposal which wasn't the case before
right play seven followed by 95 in fact
if I'm Magnus yeah there we go oh this
is this is uh 95-87 is gonna fall very
soon why doesn't the knight on c4 you
might see rook a six by Magnus oh yeah
so he's got to play nice e4 I think to
prevent Queen I to further intrusion
Queen e2 and I want to penetrate with
Queen a6 at some point yeah there we go
no we're gonna see some blood here and
it's only going to be from black side
because you know any of this issue fg5
do I know if I take on d4 just corrects
White's pawn structure if I play E for
then my bishop is aimed at d4 which is
solid and I just opened up White's
monster bishop on g3 but in the meantime
I'm just stuck with tension that I don't
know how to resolve unresolved tension
always an issue unresolved tension has
always been an issue between us too but
of a different kind
ya know I mean seriously this is uh no
this is um I'm sorry not eh I move your
rook don't overthink it if you lose
you're a pawn you lose it but but the
momentum you know it's like he makes one
bad move it's easy to make like two or
three afterwards we all do it but it's
happening happening every single time
here right Magnus seems to have finished
his spaghetti leaned in a little bit for
a while that we were just getting the
top of his hoodie he couldn't do Queenie
sixer if he just wants to trade
everything off Queen a6 and he's done
antsy so practical he could do Queen a7
but that gives up the back ran Queen a
seven wait I'm hosting goodness Evan
hangs the Queen yeah it's been that's
that's yeah I'll stay quiet for a little
bit there Danny Queen a7 is the worst
move on I don't know where that came
from
it's okay it's okay forgiving but all
right Queen trade happens white
continues to bring the noise to the a7
pawn I think probably Brooke to be seven
is a threat here 995 d5 is going to be
weak yep
c3 might be weak but if defy falls e4
becomes we could see three Falls nothing
else becomes weak so it's a favorable
trade up I'll just take here and play
with b5 yeah we could be five and this
is oh this is this is gonna be a very
pleasant game John Bartholomew yesterday
what a nice end game where he sort of
had five the majority on the king's head
black had nape on but sort of the same
thing and this is just gonna be the
initiative for whites and it's going to
be very hard to push the opponent
that's a nice move wrap everything right
off but even with you three I'll play
Ricky five and rotation X me it goes
right back to it and work a six and it's
just painful it hurts
I mean if white wants
probably played Bishop c7 and Bishop b6
and just go gobble that's right yeah
gobble gobble gobble happen he's gonna
go for the f5 pawn here he's starting to
take on that five minute flavor cap six
check but if black takes on g4 then e 4
becomes internally weak yep same story
Morning Glory it looks like white is why
just playing for two results and knowing
Magnus it's exactly the kind of result
he'll get the time situation here geez
yep well regardless of how this match
finishes which is definitely headed the
direction of a continued lopsided
victory while we have everybody here I
want to remind you that this is not the
only thing going down this week tomorrow
October 5th we have the first-ever
rated-r parental advisory blitz
deathmatch we keep things pretty clean
on twitch TV slash chests just calm TV
enjoying whatever subtle references we
can make at times me and Eric today but
Eric are you excited to see this little
matchup tomorrow with ginger GM versus
ben Feingold I'm definitely fed I like I
like to see some Ridenhour mud wrestling
yeah that's exactly what we're gonna see
with these two and to talk about the
match a little bit this is a nice moment
because magnus carlsen is in the
driver's seat we actually have been
Feingold here who wanted to get a few
words in before he's joined by Simon
Williams about exactly how he intends to
deal with Harry the H pawn and what what
Ben's gonna do there so we're actually
gonna attempt to have been joined the
show and in just a moment we will we'll
keep will keep the we'll keep the the
live board running so that everybody can
continue to follow the game but we're
gonna have been joined here Eric alright
that is actually my commentary partner
quite a bit when I haven't seen Louis so
that's right
get Ben in here bring him on let's bring
him on we know he's uh
we know he's usually quite the quite the
character Ben Feingold he said okay
Magnus is continuing to put on the
putting on the technique shoes and here
comes Ben right now we've got
we're adding let's see what are we
adding we're adding we're so beautiful
it's not easy say that again
I'm trying to make myself beautiful but
it's not easy yeah you got to get ready
to be beautiful before you pop on camera
by the way are you um are you working on
the goatee or what's going on here yeah
I got it I got a beard here yeah I got
something for a second for a GU thing
I've just not assault old school not I'm
not gonna end well you're sorry I'm
trying to get been set up here but then
we what we've done is we've added you to
the show and excited for you to be here
so first of all you've been watching the
match and as I understand Kadir Goosen
off is actually on your protest league
team as you guys attempt to qualify you
can tell he's my teammate by how well
he's doing well yeah so tomorrow you
take on Simon Williams in a death match
that's gonna be mutual trash talk back
and forth you guys are not gonna hold
back at all except for you know I'm
gonna try to keep you guys away from
vulgarity as much as possible but let
let you say whatever you want I know
that's not your style but Ben what are
you gonna how are you gonna handle Harry
the h-bond tomorrow I understand you
wanted to make a statement to Simon and
deliver it there's only one way you can
handle Harry the H blonde and that is
moving your age upon first okay so you
gotta fight Harry with Harry you can do
it little does he know my grandfather's
first name was Harry so he's in a lot of
trouble okay so who else is all your
protest League team tell us about what
you're doing here to qualify in October
well we're gonna try to qualify I think
it's October 28th right here in my chest
Center so we got Goosen off on board one
although maybe he'll be the alternate
I'm bored too and then we have one of
the top zeger [ __ ] in the world
Daniel Gurevich okay there's a lot of
there anything there like 17d or there's
a lot of derivatives yeah he's the only
one in Atlanta though and then we got
one of the best bughouse players in the
world Richard Francisco so somehow the
pro Chesley becomes bughouse I think
we're all set right okay well tomorrow
are you um do you have anything
any special surprises for Simon in store
we know that we know this thing went
viral when you called out Simon for
being an 1800 Grandmaster on the
Internet he responded I think maybe not
necessarily knowing your sense of humor
like I know your sense of humor and then
this thing kind of became an animal of
its own but are you are you preparing
for this match like a serious chess
match and how much are you fighting for
not just the prize money but pride
against the ginger GM no you're right
Danny I did a lot of serious preparation
and I got my notes right here I wrote
many many you know you know jokes and
insults okay I've been working for a few
weeks now and I think I think I got my
insults down I think I'm ready I think I
think I'm ready for this match all right
well that's good Eric even though Ben's
here I'm gonna ask you to make a
prediction of this match who do you
think who use what do you see going down
tomorrow which mean Ben and Simon know
that Ben is listen did you get that
money transfer since we are unable to go
but my prediction yeah you know what I
also have been and I think to say that
Simon's gonna be upset I also have been
winning Ben apparently we think you're
slightly better than Simon Williams Wow
I bribed the right guys excellent I knew
those transfers came in my life told me
they came in just right so my main
reason is that I think Simon has the
tendency to go on tilt more than Ben
does I think you both have tilt
tendencies I was born on sill so I can't
really go on so that's just static
that's just the way it is yeah well you
know in all seriousness though we can't
wait for tomorrow the fans that are here
you came to see Magnus Carlsen maybe you
got a little bit of a preview tomorrow
is gonna be a I will say this it's not
gonna be as lopsided as this I doubt
either one of these guys runs away with
it with right now what is an 11-point
lead for Magnus Carlsen so yeah running
running isn't either one of our strong
suits Danny we're not going to be
running did you see the video today it
looks like he can run a little bit but
not too much Oh
Simon yeah you saw that video Simon made
Oh a training video oh yeah a training
video for how he's taking you on that's
correct yeah that's you guys gotta find
that it's somewhere on YouTube I don't
know where I saw Simon tweeted I just
didn't watch it yet so I'll check it out
yeah you should you should watch that
you'll see the great prep that he does
yeah well everyone you can follow Simon
on Twitter ginger GM you can follow Ben
on Twitter the CCS a basically the Chess
Club Scholastic Center of Atlanta just
figure I know it's a lot of letters a
lot of consonants Spelling's not my
songs my strong suit then you opened up
a chest in Atlanta I'm gonna let you do
a free plug here tell everybody what
you're doing in Atlanta because honestly
I've heard phenomenal things and you
know I don't give you compliments very
often and people have donated to the
show just because they're so happy with
the work you're doing in Atlanta so tell
everybody what you're doing the more you
donate the more you learn well we
realized that there's nowhere to play
chess in Atlanta so my wife Karen and I
decided to open a chess Center it took
us seven months to get this place ready
we had a grand opening our grand opening
blitz tournament September 9th at 74
pliers which is more than twice what we
expected we were shocked and we had
about a hundred and forty people show up
overall just to hang out and the big
news of the day was I was planning on
ordering about 15 pizzas for everybody
so we could have some food for tomorrow
I ordered 48 pizzas 72 wings a hundred
breadsticks 150 cookies and they were
gone in minutes gone so chess players
I'm not sure how good they were at chess
but they're good at eating and that was
today we got some hungry chess players
here in Atlanta Danny was that today
been no that was September 9th oh that
was my dinner last night
i meanwe that was our grand opening okay
yeah you got it
well Eric I know you get enough of been
in st. Louis maybe you're both maybe you
both have had enough of st. Louis and
now you're in your own places but
anything you want to say to mr. Feingold
before we let him go me yeah no I picked
him I just want to see I just want to
see a dirty fight you know what a clean
fair fight I want to see I want to see
the dirty fight and I'm hoping he can
come up with good trash talk he always
picks on Canada by the way yeah well I
mean naturally it's his best repertoire
I couldn't hear what Eric says he has to
tell me later
yeah come up with some good stuff
tomorrow I got it all right well Benny
says you always pick on Canada I said
obviously as you should but
we are gonna let you go make sure you
have as many picking on Englishman jokes
as you do look at Canadian jokes and yes
we will see you tomorrow everybody don't
don't miss the match tomorrow it's gonna
be a lot of fun and also prizes being
donated to charity so we're putting
these guys potty-mouthed to a good cause
before you think it's all it's all
terrible so then have a good day in
Atlanta watch the rest of this routing
of your future protests League teammate
maybe give him some advice and we'll
talk to you later all right thanks Danny
see you guys tomorrow
yep all right that was grandmaster bent
feingold surprised drop-in but he was he
was he's texting me and chat with me
wanted to join the show so I figured hey
it's a routing why not why not mix it up
a little bit yeah for sure I just want
to say for the first time Magnus was in
serious trouble I'm not sure I think he
was in serious trouble now he's up a
piece right yeah but why did he give up
a piece hey
what I'll be honest that was Laura Clark
just gave a piece back but I thought
Magnus was gonna lose it just distracted
no it's okay but Magnus somehow want a
piece we've gone back to the analysis
board over here and tried it to look
goofy now just gave the piece thinking
he's gonna check me he took on v6
thinking it was over I just really
confused me here and now either Magnus
is gonna win or well this is just
winning but he was in serious trouble
position instead of Queen to f3 he could
just play Knight to e3 and that defense
the rook and white is just white is just
crushing it stopped up on on c6 for the
rest of the game so just very well
that's gonna talk speaking of tilt
that's the bishop da there we go game
over King a6 king b5 that is just that
is heartbreaking Ferguson off right
there right I mean that I mean I just
backed up in the analysis because I
missed it I was talking with them but
that's just you're like you said that's
just um inexplicable that's so excited
that he might be they beating Magnus
that he sort of stopped calculating or
God
careless there yeah Magnus can just play
b5 and then and then King to b6 right
yeah I mean you know Magnus is in
trouble when he's got 20 seconds and the
other guy has two minutes so it was one
of those situations where he's probably
should have spent a bit of time to close
out oh oh wow this is waiting for white
oh whoa what just happened was that
always winning oh my gosh but it we're
gonna see a victory
who wants a victory I want a victory and
God dear Hussein up is on the board
everybody woo the crowd goes wild did we
miss something there was that always
winning yeah I have no idea honestly um
hey I didn't count you know I don't know
but thinking thinking back about it it
makes me think it was always winning cuz
I didn't realize that he was playing f6
I thought he was playing a e6 and then
taking back yeah me too
so that's so the FS now that we know
that f6 was the idea I think adir was
winning and uh well look at that Eric we
have a victory hey come on everybody
he's got noise god he's got that he's
got yeah yeah Magnus is yawning and he's
like yeah whatever I still got orange I
still got orange spaghetti sauce on my
lips okay Magnus is uh he's about ready
to burn a nap you could tell you can
tell he's gonna he's gonna hit that hit
the hay after this only eight minutes
left in the three minute portion then we
have chess960
and in a final a final section of one
minute everybody
but this has been the Magnus show it's
been the masterclass by Magnus Carlsen
so if you want to learn how to play
blitz like a champion I guess watch a
replay of this if you're just joining us
it has been a lopsided victory we can't
pretend that it hasn't been not going to
be a Wesley so onigiri type finish today
everybody but sponsored by masterclass
that's the speech Chess Championship go
to masterclass comm slash chess and
check out Garry Kasparov scumming course
we will play the trailer for you at this
break here and remind you in case you
didn't know that you can learn from the
world champion here very soon what's
going on here this
samer oxy bond gone bad yeah well he
always plays accelerated so when I said
he sort of has no repertory and he like
plays it quickly and you know some news
this is the exact line but he always
employs and that's all he's ended up
with a bit of a time edge
yeah and matured mangas can get the but
mangas seemed to have blundered the
night on e7 but he found sis move be for
everybody which threatens work a-one
trapping the Queen before working one of
Queen is 65 is is not gonna be good part
of the reason he couldn't play 95 back
everybody as GRU say enough could have
captured and then taken with the Queen
because the e pawn was pinned so b4 was
both a trick and I think kind of a
necessity for Magnus to play yeah so
he's still trying to talk about green
with rook a one yep and how was who
saying off getting out of that now uh
you can play a five-year if you want ah
before yeah that'll work
a five rook a one Queen before he gets
out but even if he does get out Magnus
pops back to d5 now there's no trick of
winning a pawn and I think white is just
better in this endgame depends on how
good I five is before yeah yeah good
point that's a that's a good point by
Eric everybody after his live and yeah
see this is an opening Magnus allowed
you didn't need to allow it and this is
literally like what Hussein up knows
really well that's funny play blitz and
in classical and in rapid it's his main
opening that ain't that he's known for
right so he's able to rattle off the
moves and knows the structure he's gonna
find the moves here so and you can tell
the difference to one time right when
Godwin gideros comfortable versus when
he's not and here comes f5 and I agree
with you it's looking closer and closer
like he's buggin oh no I mean before so
no I Roxy would have run into Queen 67
but why just defend the pawn but black
is gonna capture and then bring this
night from g7 it I was gonna say maybe
not fi yeah maybe he can come in to f4
and that provides more problems for
white so I think I mean if Kadir wins
this one that might wake up Magnus right
it would be two in a row and I think
that though it is still on the road to a
very lopsided victory that would be
enough to kind of wake mate wake Magnus
up Magnus is relaxed Kadir hasn't really
moved all day except for when his camera
disappears on us rook 81 here and he's
probably gonna be happy to win the
endgame maybe not rookie 5 Riki 5 and I
think I do win d5 but at what cost
because work a 7 might come in on the
end game I don't think it's good for a
block because of the king position so 94
looks like c4 but what about if 94
you're saying cake with the rook yeah
yeah take with the rook ok and after
chase everything I want to play you
found at some point and use that deep on
to run down the board before got it so
just showing the fans though later yeah
calculating never yeah so good there
goes for this idea of the d5 font
hanging and just a fence b7 with the
move rook f7 you can go check on it and
play rook to D aids here check King g7
rook d8 hitting d6 perhaps good deer
would play the move Knight to e8 there
well then I mean one thing I want to do
at some point is I want to play b6 sort
of fixing up on on on b7 and can you
control the c7 spurt okay so we're
getting a transition into the endgame
that opens things up got an okay
position here just just then his clocks
okay but this was really Magnus allowing
him to play an opening that he knows
very well he's an expert in yeah still
still can go both ways bishop you for
cookie not know maybe bishop f1 I'm
guessing I want to play g3 not for put
my pawns on dogs first with my bishop on
G but G to put pressure on e7 so bishop
f1 g3 have for Bishop g2 now be
gypsy4now I wanna go Bishop c4 why did
he allow that yeah yeah that's a blunder
fortunes did not yet he does it right
away
I is trick good stuff he has a trick
everybody Magnus missed it and so did we
if Bishop takes rook in d7 and black
actually wins a piece so that means
Magnus has just lost a significant tempo
no especially if I get in 95 King g7 +
b6 than I am
and I'm really really happy and the
reason why Eric loves that everybody
just okay here comes King g7 but if you
know let's just say if Black gets this
sort of thing where b7 isn't a weakness
anymore it protects the night things are
just really calm and collected over
there on the Queen side and then and
then goose a good deer could try to work
on on using his past deep on so so
Magnus's is again I mean as you said
Kadir knows these little all the little
tricks in this position well whatever
you know it opening it's not just the
theory all the common tactics that occur
after that are things you're very
familiar with so Kadir has played this
position well it's gonna go okay seven
rookies ed is gonna sacrifice the dog
live the script okay seven and Magnus is
gonna lose he does it Magnus sees that
but he's still in trouble if rook a one
King c1 and king b2 and you're not
allowed in Oh Magnus holding by the hair
he was a very nice very nice move it's
thought it's that's really cool
yeah that's honestly like look at Kadir
he's frustrated - I'm frustrated he's
frustrated he's leaning in it's not a
move you want a minute because there's
gonna stuck there for a long time
yeah you just hate when a rook is
guarding a pawn like that any place
would be one here comes your move king
c1 he does have 93 check in that
position
okay then King says ooh right in the 91
check and I can go after GG so I mean I
mean things to do right away
och equals e2 instead first yeah I see
in a b3 you have king b2 and I've run
out of moves to play okay but he goes to
c1 why is he allowing oh well if 93
Kings to do of 91 I play King bee - how
do you play 93 Kings you to this b3
check that's what I was worried about ah
he's going for the rook ending yes where
I don't think he'll who's King takes d3
rook takes me one rook takes b6 but but
probably Magnus ain't game Oh actually
the problem is the b-pawn is blocking
Hawks work from karbala from this this
could easily get ranked is playing for a
win in this position just shocking right
now so d4 King before b2 King back to c2
in his form there's no look c1 check
because the rock on c6 is protected so
d4 the way that doesn't work actually
because if if d4 King before d3 q c3 he
actually has check because
by the pond you take I have B to D for
right now I take the pond
okay okay I see what you're saying I
thought you were saying D for right away
Oh No okay King of seven and again look
a good deer being down on time but it's
just shocking to me that with this extra
this one and the more active King white
is actually playing for a win here if he
takes the pawn Sounds playing rook c1
getting the King off yeah let's show
that's really instructive cuts the King
off and then good deer would win with
the movie okay play some good news here
goose a mob is putting posing some
questions as to how you you stopped
those pawns King me seven stopping work
T six behind the pond like that rook c6
that king can come here and here we go
you can't push the pawn anymore so yeah
gooo say enough is defending this
position well still this is even those
out of the opening this is also an
endgame that he's probably had before
this type of endgame I bet do you three
is a threat d3 is a threat why not d3
now what am I missing
yeah we're gonna find out oh it's gonna
be a race they're both gonna do they're
both gonna Queen like this white is
saying my king is safer because your
rook is cut out cut off this is
delicioso Dora I love it a lot more
exciting than I thought this was gonna
be honestly bring the king Oh keeps
coming up king b6 Queen Shaq he can even
come all the way cuz Queen B 4 check
allows rook b6 going all the way yeah
king b7 just do it
what if queen bee for Chuck never upbeat
sex right Queenie for Chuck no the pods
their queen before I'm 24
no but the turn f3 can take the Queen oh
it's easy to miss that because the king
is on there's other board you forget
over the pawns
yeah no I think I think Magus was
actually winning there which again
that's like Wow right that is one of
those like games that Magnus just turned
around and get dere is looking to the
side he's obviously frustrated what
there's something to be said he should
not be fighting when Eve increments
he should not be fine you should make a
move I mean he's flagged multiple times
yep you just have to make a move I mean
he's clearly having some serious time
issues because I might get low on time
but then I like start moving quicker to
actually fly yep and story no and that
is the end of the three no you're
totally right in fact one time I was
given a piece of advice by Gregory
Kedarnath and he said the worst blunder
you can ever make is losing on time
because it ends the game even if you're
making a move that allows checkmate 1
they may not see it right ok it's an
extreme example but it's the point is
you're right you the worst thing you can
do is lose yourself and who knows the
most that might happen nice or no right
so you just can't beat yourself on time
you have to make a blunder rather than a
timeout always know all right
Kasane off has white again in the
chess960 game he did have white the
first time am i right am I remembering
correctly
who yeah I think so I think so yeah yeah
okay well gideros uh you know what he's
he's been given a tough matchup that's
the truth and he's on pace if he gets a
game and a half a game or two then he's
he's beaten petrosian's record he hasn't
let magnus carlsen gotten get the the
biggest lopsided victory ever if he as
long as he can get a couple more points
yeah but that's the goal you never want
to be the example you don't want to be
the history of somebody else's somebody
else's record-breaking performance right
but I mean is this was this really a
chess960 position look at this game well
this is good for gusano he has chances a
960 games these are weird positions and
and I know but what I'm saying is it
doesn't
look pretty normal I mean this looks
like hooks looks pretty normal yeah I
like blue Santos position I like the -
yeah that's why I didn't think it was
normal Danny
[Music]
yeah people just TV chat I'm sorry the
the chest comm game chat if you want to
follow along the game of course you can
do so directly in chess calm and play
guess the move have some fun so but I
see a lot of a lot of crazy comments
there well regardless of the result in
this game Eric it's an 11-point lead
right now for Carlsen it would take the
most epic collapse of all time in bullet
I think moats more likely as we're just
gonna see a lot of fun stuff in bullet
and look at Magnus already mixing up
this one here comes Knight h4 doesn't it
oh no he's not gonna sack the piece I
guess he'll play yeah something else but
actually gue st. of is doing okay here
because these Knights can't really move
without opening up the battery of the
Queen and Bishop to the king so despite
doubling the pawns I still like goose
and ups position here right no I do for
sure yeah you it's unbalanced he's got
attacking a chance this push the pawns
use those bishops and there you go this
is this is a great position to push
Queen b3
Park your bishop on e4 maybe put your
King on h1 move your books to g1 and
open it up that's great bishop you four
kings you want I can teach one sorry
what you want and I'm happy yeah you
know watch out Queen age three is coming
out right h1 King at one I mean what why
is he thinking you put your king on each
one yeah yeah let's do it he's coming in
anyway and after Knight takes f3 you're
gonna have to play bro cheat you okay so
Magnus isn't gonna go for it right away
Gustav is doing exactly exactly what he
has to do here and now it's all about
solving that issue how do I move my
night off
and started talking madness so queen d3
here maybe queen d3 and i want to you
know threaten bishop play Bishop a5
sometime or bishop c3 and trade he's
gonna trade okay this is either also
good enough
well his ideas 96 f1 and rook g4 because
I think c4 is hanging right yeah Knight
takes d4 Brook g4 wins apiece actually I
thought it did but there's g5 well then
it's just what's going on there he
blundered again and the Queen's are off
which okay it's still a fine position
for white being that despite big down
pawn because of the strength of the
bishops and the center but right that
was a probably not done no no something
was done incorrectly there he blundered
the bond that was a pawn but that's
unnecessary
Magnus works at least at least he
sacrificed now now he's gonna go over do
you wanna and push the pawns but he let
you let Magnus off the hook there
there's definitely some missed
opportunities he's not able to string to
the other combinations he hasn't been
able to yeah at this much at some point
the momentum always shifts to Magnus
he's offered at Red Queen's when I
thought Queens should've been on the
board but right we'll see ya nervous
more nervous about Magnus's pressure as
you said he's in he's in reaction mode a
lot not not executing aggressively and
now here comes something with the F pawn
maybe nine f5 if you want get rid of the
bishops Bishop c5 okay for maybe well
this is definitely not a 960 style
position it's just one where Magnus is
up the exchange and White has some
compensation if you trade the bishop you
open up the c2 square for Magnus so
that's why that's why white doesn't want
to trade but if he doesn't trade Eric
then the knight pops into e3 so so black
is black is driving right driving the
bus
know as those pieces we get trade off
that that space advantage gain from
those pawns is pretty much meaningless
the exchange is gonna this is lost
yeah the d5 pawn Falls and with it with
it yes you had a nice position for money
and I don't even know what happened
there right I mean it was a I mean Queen
f1 is a very bizarre move to me unless
unless he just I don't know I yep I'm
gonna let the players know remind them
that they do have a break let Magnus
know as he's asking break time okay good
dear has stepped away Magnus kind of
sitting there but now he's aware he can
also step away if he would like to for a
minute but Eric you know this is this is
getting it's not out of control it's
been out of control Magnus Carlsen
greatest greatest chess player on the
planet right now not a big surprise but
it definitely seems that Kadir is also
beating himself a little bit at this
point would that be fair yes I mean the
frustration is set in and it's can't
blame him you see it all the time in
speech as matches the momentum plays a
big big role so hard to to get those
ideas out of your head that I'm just
blundering I'm just frustrated the tilt
tilt is real you you know it might not
be physical like me throwing a chair
just on your mind your mind is more
dangerous where you're just you lost
your confidence your you start believing
your opponent's moves every time just
just yeah anybody who didn't know that
you threw a chair in one of your videos
can now go check that out because that
was a great reference but I'm gonna
invite everybody to tune in right now to
the trailer for Garry Kasparov master
class course you may have seen it on the
web
watching some YouTube videos maybe any
any video on the web or maybe you
watched in our previous speeches
championship match but Garry Kasparov
it's the first time he's ever done
anything like this it may be the last
you don't want to miss it so let's go
ahead and tune into the trailer here and
we will let the players have their
remaining 90 second break and then we
will start the one-minute portion
check chess is a game of a minute of
beauty but it's not just checks and
attacks you have to be creative
I'm here to share with you my knowledge
of the game of chess but I'm trying to
come up with the comprehensive picture
that will be helpful for you to become a
better chess player and even a better
decision aid that's covered in g5 king
c2 King f6 can be speaking with seven
King supporting the sixteen before King
Cecil King racing boom white lost yes
Quinn takes and Knight f5 and it's
double attack skew and traction and its
mate but an amazing mate how can we
prevent this rook from stopping our porn
let's pause stop the video and see you
have time to find this winning
combination did you see that it's your
visual
whether certain you have Nazi [ __ ] I'd
ever say that that's that's interesting
so you attack my mission then you
protect your vision right so let's go
back and see whether we can improve and
what's the next logical rules
it's about coming up with new ideas
challenging your own excellence to find
your mistakes next time you have better
I've been thinking about a few ideas
that I never used one I want to show
it's another sacrifice
I'd like sacrifices and it's one of my
favorite obliques so just let's have a
look
we cannot waste time time is precious
you don't feel that the game can leash
your creative potential then you already
losing something it's not about winning
or losing
and of course at the end of the day it's
about winning I'm Gary Kasparov and this
is my master class you heard the man
Eric at the end of the day it's about
winning or losing and at the end of the
day it's about winning or losing
at the end of the day Magnus Carlsen
he's on the way it went right absolutely
he's doing what he does best and I mean
he he won his first classical chess
event in over a year
you gotta think I was a something to get
off the shoulders he's really in his
element right now beneath when Magnus is
like playing good chess like play he
just can't be stopped
yeah we've seen some of the most
dominant performances in history by him
and this might not necessarily be like
you know his normal opposition but not
giving opponents space
hardly ever making blunders excellent
time management doing all the little
things really really well and converting
whenever do given the opportunities
that's that's him well said and yeah as
you said Isle of Man victory there a big
victory not that Magnus suffers from
confidence that often but yeah Knight
nice to get a win and and now he's he's
really putting on a show here although
this game something went wrong there
with Magnus bringing out the dark square
bishop as we can see he kind of had to
tuck his tail and back up but feels like
black is doing okay here we like that I
don't have for you like the potential
attacking chances maybe I'm wrong maybe
Magnus is getting no no side first but
black is doing a block is doing good for
sure yeah the blunder is something
happened but it's a bullet game and at
least in this portion the players will
make a few more mistakes and it's just
let's just see if goose a knife can
manage this time better it'll be a lot
more unforgiving in this format well
only a half an hour left until we move
into the the last chest nine
the game of course if you're just
joining us as you've seen the scoreboard
is pretty lopsided in the direction of
the of the one and only Magnus Carlsen
also if you're just joining us if you
haven't had an opportunity yet to dive
into our our challenge our our Photoshop
challenge you can do some somebody did a
mustache on Magnus actually as as a we
we we we jump over here somebody
somebody confusing what we were asking
for did a Photoshop for a mustache on
Magnus not necessarily crazy here we're
looking for but if you still want to get
involved with a chance to win a one your
diamond membership though a Photoshop
together of either yourself or just show
us your craziest hairstyle ever and
honor of Magnus Carlson's hairstyle
Magnuson trouble he's in trouble yeah I
got to see it what do we got oh he
wasn't because Bishop takes have to run
into oh okay he was worth okay I thought
he was in trouble he still might be in
trouble but I thought was gonna be a bit
worse Queen takes Queen takes
oh that's made its made out g1 so you
couldn't take it
Queen g1 okay and he's only got 10
seconds to so this is a rare a rare
Magnus fresh under pressure sighting
nice move King f2 yeah that might force
the draw might be one of the weirdest no
King f3 no draw
there's no Bishop d5 cuz it's pinned
there's no more checks yesterday huh
this is the kind of fighting chess we
were looking all good stuff
I thought Brooke takes she eight would
have been the answer there ah but he
Wiggles his way that's disgusting
Danny that was nasty that's too much
it's not even fair Oh like he's chillin
one after he's like you got out you
immediately recognize that and he just
you're never ever getting a check that
was just that was absolutely nasty that
was that was brilliant stuff there the
King walks up to f3 and look at that
awareness and look at how quickly he he
knew not to take them thank you dear
lost you know there's nothing he could
do he just looked to the side and kind
of shrugged his head everyone could see
it on camera just like well another one
bites the dust against Magnus Carlsen
it was it was instructive how he
around pond you do not always have to
take those pawns you can use them as
shields right and that's a great example
of using it and persevering yeah no that
was that was that's one you might want
to backup fans take another closer look
at especially from a practical being
better at blitz and bullet perspective
like Eric said you don't always have to
play the forceful taking move all right
well here Magnus is being forceful and
taking pieces he's gone he's gone greedy
Ganesh over here
greedy Guillermo he took that beep on
he's gonna open up the queenside did
your mo has not been to present today
but he'll come out at some point he
usually does but ok Magnus's is Dancing
with the Queen but I think black is
totally fine here yeah black buck is
fine it seems pretty balanced to can be
met by I guess even d4 and try to bring
the knight into default he's gonna go
friend who's gonna say if Magnus gets
into n games I'd like almost always put
him as a massive favorite yeah this was
some sort of relatively balanced endgame
and this might be another example look
at mo rookie 3 fork
he 5 is falling the critical thing here
is to get the name on c7 to square the
key for c4 somewhere better than is
right now then I'll be able to evaluate
this a bit better so tonight d5 and 93
okay okay he's quickly activated at
night he activates PC so like just
immediately he sees something wrong and
he goes to work right away what's the
what's the best square that night on you
six very centralized but okay Bishop I
mean generally Bishop should be better
in open position and that does the
bishop is guarding a2 and and maybe
hitting f7 so we'll see if you know
Kadir is obviously poking at the pawn
everybody these games are pretty
competitive Magnus says he's not back
down and he's allowing them to be quite
practical in nature and right which
makes it even more impressive those so
many games making for
you blunders but job but yeah here here
you say no if is doing okay that bishop
okay he's giving up the mission was
gonna say the bishop is the best minor
piece on the board but but apparently he
doesn't care
I mean bizarre decision what can I say
thought that was a good Bishop and yeah
because blocks play very easy look if
the rooks were off the board you push
the hedge fund maybe one route goes off
the board pair works was about four
stage now he's now it works it's not so
simple to just push me pushes this pawn
to you far everybody look for mating
nets on the H file so yeah definitely
you know at some point if I was black I
might go for a jog with King be 1605 I
do have to time that properly it's a
nice little move they were kept three
yeah taking advantage of the pin but
unfortunately for way he's got Richie
seven covering G to it wants to play h5
with upon not being pinned okay before
now why did you know why a four maybe
five I'm happy to do that this seems
like thank you very much please deficit
direction of positive this is you're
going the opposite direction of positive
right now this is not ideal
how did that happen is it there no no he
should have just done what you said once
he once he established the work on g7 it
was defending g2 he sitter started
pushing the H pawn stuff even there
everybody white would have loved to have
traded and taken the rook on c2 but you
got an f3 but then you get the Queen so
just um so many bratwurst endgame so
quickly I mean this is Oh
Kadir is gonna be very upset about that
because he knew he was better than game
at one point and he knew he probably
should have been quicker right he had to
make a lot of mistakes without to happen
the way well luckily forged ear this
nightmare is only 20 minutes away from
ending it's a it's a frustrating day
here for the Serie but you know he's um
I guess he's been principled so we
wanted him to mix it up let's give him
let's make it a positive thing he's been
principal Derek he's been principal just
too little too late
yeah and Magnus has been sort of the one
allowing that to happen
yeah so when I'm looking back on it well
maybe I'll see some questions for for
afterwards but he needed to be a bit
more direct himself in enforcing the the
balances yeah well now we've got a Kings
on opposite side of the board game which
is usually a fun one for attacking
chances problem is that not only for
blocks everything and Asia but on f1
guards b5 this is just lost those are
good just loss has just lost though but
you get mangas one more movies gonna
play something like g4 and h5 it just
bust open blacks game you can't move any
of your pieces of block this is actually
very sad Queen d6 is gonna be this is
this is uh yeah white might even play b6
here b6 or take on c6 play Bishop to e5
with tempo yeah I mean this is this is
playing itself the bullet ratings are
even more there's an even bigger
disparity between the 3200 the Magnus
Carlsen boasts on our site
I'm surprised to see enemies rating is
2400 I don't know if he's a very active
bullet player because I mean let's be
honest that's lower than my bullet
rating right
so certainly I would think he's he's
better than that maybe just not actively
playing enough to raise that rating if
Magnus finishes the bullet portion under
3200 I think we can consider that a
moral victory for juicing up a small
victory the little things that count now
this is uh definitely looking a bit like
50 shades of chess or something this
sort of position graphic Magnus is uh is
the doctor here and he's uh he's having
his way yep this is this is rough have
you seen those movies by the way I've
never seen them which one do you know I
have not I have not no I have not never
drove into the Fifty Shades of Grey and
now there's like another one coming out
yeah I know mom likes them so I've
always been curious about the
yeah the the seventh rank is gonna be a
problem for you say enough and it almost
hurts to just just wait for when the the
tactics are coming in Ali it's hurting
it's hurting here he comes
you can even take I thought he was gonna
take d8 and play Knight f6 check but
that was unnecessary so no and not good
actually yeah this is rough Eric we got
problems and goosing off town we will
keep the scoreboard above us even though
we kill me dude yeah I don't expect
things to change too much well he found
a way to put his bishop back on g7
that's response most comfortable but
this is tough I mean I can always be
critical at the end of the day he's
playing Magnus though and it's just it
is so hard if Magnus wants to shut you
down she does it he's the very very very
best players in the world so I mean even
even with let's say a different game
plan you have no guarantee of a lot of
space or opportunity in Magnus you know
he's not he's not letting up at all I
mean psychologically he's just as sharp
as he was before you know he's keeping
his edge and and and yeah so we seem to
have lost Kadir a little bit what do you
mean by the I mean I'm cut into off
against and you couldn't have but I'm
fixing it so as best I can until they
move over no no you don't need to go
back here but I'm fine going side to
side we can we're going around a bit so
you're open to different positions is
what you're telling me oh yeah the the
positions right now are just running out
of control here for
well here he's got space Danny he's got
space here this is a good position for a
while objectively he's got space get in
now for move that night away from have
three 9h to f4 play d5 enough for use
that space advantage for something sharp
please go for the good position this is
definitely good position this is like a
good Brier or something yeah it's bullet
though this is a time where Magnus
doesn't have time like this is this is
the moment where it's gonna be hard to
be accurate as block yeah if he can be
aggressive he's being positional and
things like that but go on the kingside
yeah yeah I agree forget about b49 h2 +
f4 because may mean time is improving
his pieces that Bishop on g7 no okay
we'll see Queen c1 Freddie involved
Freddie Freddie all right there you go
that's necessary let's go let's go now
here comes a five there we go maybe just
sleep rook f1 bring the rook back to the
F file sure quickly no you have to
defend you [ __ ] yeah but now I take him
play Bishop g7 white still has to have
something here here we go we were
waiting for 9f5 Julio grand up without
eating Simone and olive man it's it's
very tough to face over the board here's
the Kings gonna tuck itself away if this
Queen could just get itself good five
six five six and put that Bishop and
Queen on the same diagonal at six Bishop
Bishop e1 this should be one I won't put
my queen on c2 I don't care about the
rook yep here we go you'll take with the
Queen and the Queen comes III that's
over this is this is almost the meeting
then I think yes okay one I think Magnus
has rook a 100 look at the Queen see a
check if Queen d3 I think there's oh I'd
never I thought I think there's bishops
you want check and then what what
happened
was that was that the expected journey
for this position I don't think I'm
waiting for the moves Oh King and [ __ ]
taketake I think he just has to settle
on the draw a lot of talk no action in
this one apparently because I think
we're I think we're settling not even
Magnus can get out of this perpetual as
much as he'd like to
all right well Kadir gets himself one
game closer to not losing not being a
footnote right he needs to get a bullet
and a half he needs to get a game and a
half victory here and bullet to not go
down by a score larger than Tigran
Petrosian did last year Magnus Carlsen
is that was better that was better
bye-bye ddr2 to play play aggressively
like that can still be improved on and
it's a little late but this these ball
games can go either way
a lot of these games have been so I
think there's decent chances Danny how
much time does he have eight minutes he
has and he do uh go back to the to the
time you know he's got 14 minutes
okay 14 minutes so you got time to get a
few a few wins here so we will uh we'll
see what he can do here is black in this
weird closest it's all about to swing my
sword right now seeing if it hits
something oh the blunder but you know
what I'm calling a win for Magnus
I'm calling this to be a win for Magnus
Danny he's bunting the Queen for two
pieces but this is we're gonna see some
nasty maneuvering with minors okay well
I can't wait that I'm predicting the win
for Magnus here I think he's really
going to he's gonna he's gonna put on
the the maneuvering pants he actually
actually is I do you own a pair of
maneuvering pants or is that against
chest broad dress-code like I know you
guys are really into tight euro jeans
like I've got some maneuverability
chance we're in the Euro gene industry
but yeah
remember when baggy cargo pants were a
thing are you too young for that sort of
too young for that but in terms of
maneuvering we we have some shorts and
some other things at home if we want
them and over a bit more we have
homemade equipment I
I like jeans that are flexible so I can
do squats in them oh look at this you
ever go to the gym with jeans now of
course I wouldn't either but you never
know when you just need to like bust out
a squat set like Crossman happens
everywhere buddy you're a CrossFit okay
now this is looking a bit ugly the
bishop 182 is not the sort of piece I
was 23 has made everybody and it's
coming I think uh and the Eric's
prediction was bold but I think it will
be wrong and I think you say enough gets
him one gets himself one step closer to
not being a footnote in the history book
of Magnus Carlsen yeah
well based on the way the games were
going there was a decent chance he's
gonna score women because they don't
know I I didn't I didn't I didn't call
you out right then because I thought you
might be right believe me I understand
but but yeah it looks like you seen
everyone on the road victory here or a
queen edge one check everything works
yeah I'm surprised this game is still
going there we go alright
not as many guess the movers anymore
apparently people got tired of trying to
guess what gu seeing off my play next
he's what we're trying to guess when
he's gonna rejoin us on camera I've let
like a deer know that we lost him on a
technical level we're back we're back to
the pier so this time again the colors
are reversed
Magnus is black the the score I'm gonna
predict will not be as bad as Petrosian
Carlsen I'm gonna predict that at some
point in the next 10 minutes goose ain't
off gets at least a draw so I'm on
record now goose a knife will not go
down as the biggest lock lopsided lost a
Magnus I mean the honest truth is that
the closest match Magnus has had so far
was it the Greek man I mean again sorrow
he really he really pulled away there
was Grisha because he was only up one
game after both time controls yeah yeah
and the portion did Magnus boy those the
Greece Turkey
we shook is a very tough opponent for
Magnus ya know a stylistic Lee if you I
agree with you totally in fact you
remember I actually picked Rick to pull
that upset and that was a horrible pick
in hindsight but it was partly because I
didn't know how good Magnus wasn't
bullet I didn't know and now I know so I
mean it's like I know I would never pick
against Hikaru in the bullet portion but
I I just didn't know how good Magnus was
and bullet and he and he really gave
Corsica beat down there but um but I
think stylistically Gustav max matches
up well with Magnus he's beaten Magnus
in the world blitz championship before
so if grishnack takes down MBL and
magnus takes down Wesley so as we move
over to the to the bracket here which I
think we can update at this point as
Magnus Carlsen moving on and my team has
already done that
I think if Magnus takes down so and
Grichuk beats MBL that's a that's a
semifinals rematch from last year
that'll be big but yeah so we haven't
announced our hosts yet obviously Eric
and I will definitely be back you know
at least for a couple we've got other
hosts who are gonna jump in on this
we've got the we've got the later rounds
of the speech Chess Championship coming
up so everyone should stay tuned we
already announced the dates earlier
today on the show the next match will be
October 23rd grishnack versus MBL is the
next time you're gonna see the
speechless championship on twitch we
will be announcing all details of those
things shortly so who do you got in
these who do you got going all the way
in this you're gonna you're gonna go
with Magnus yes because uh the other
ones I don't know how to pick netbook or
the other ones are all toss-ups but I
definitely take Magnus over so in his
night in the next match that would be my
my first prediction yeah it would be a
it would be a safe one alright well go
ahead yeah no just kusenov now is uh is
getting closer to another win here Danny
yeah we like that he's uh we like that
good okay so you can take you can't take
on e4 cuz of it may be for throne in
Queen takes b4 may be Rick c7 is the
idea uh-huh yeah he was trying to
deflect the Queen away from that c7 so
working for some possible cause of Queen
a one check grant issues on f2 d3 check
ah
the discovery what gone wild anyone came
over I just work I've a check okay or
this well goose and I was doing really
well that yeah yeah you had the pressure
is winning he started taking too much
time which happens all the time you you
have too many choices yeah he beat
himself there because I think that it
was a safe prediction to think he might
get might get past that he needs to get
one more draw one more victory here to
get out of that four spot well Magnus
going back to this Larson he's been
getting great positions with this
structure he the place I have three here
usually g4 this should be five but okay
night night before Bishop f5 is the idea
this is by five rook c1
yep you here for White House chief war
and then the moves coming with tempo now
right mm-hmm
but b5 is coming too and I think he will
play maybe Queen b8 and be thought okay
b5 right away Magnus is saying look take
on a for my Knights gonna be happy there
yep okay well this doesn't seem
inspiring because now there's no more
potential in the a file yeah black is
just black is on full tilt here
sacrifice every pawn until something
becomes open before yep close it up
the you take with the D pawn and then
play g5 at some point here
White is
Wow bb5 was a little surprising but I
guess some c4 he's gonna just use that
pawn mass like Queen before or something
use that pawn mass and and turn the
tables I liked me before to avoid this
option that's why I want to keep all the
plans so this is the clink e3 yeah g5 is
a threat yes they're coming funny enough
the two bishops Magnus is totally okay
here down the exchanges entry 598 Knight
age 5 yeah or I can just move my queen
all the way to stop Bishop takes b5
ideas I can just say I've just better
pieces playing with like Queen before
you couldn't before 95-97 shot Queen
before king b1 uh-huh just secured I
still like nineties 5 but I wonder is
there okay at age five year cuz if
Knight takes g7 yeah something bothered
him there I'm not sure what maybe you
have six yeah yeah so he's willing to
give up the b-pawn for the exchange but
guste enough is trying for more now he's
threatening Knight takes which is a good
idea cuz that will come with tempo on
the Queen this isn't so convincing this
is uh all these games are quite I think
I mean Magnus is having fun in this in
this portion he's he's allowing it to be
a bit sharper and I mean who say I'm
showing that he's not that bad at these
chaotic positions yeah just welcome the
bullet portion to to go into them yeah
yeah I like these tactics Bishop f5
these quick tactics you're showing I
mean he's known for being pretty pretty
good applets and pretty sharp so he's
got rooked e8 if King e1 Queen e3 of
King e2 then 94 so yeah must be Bishop
d3 after rook da defends it but now this
is a better version he's probably got at
least a draw here actually yeah it's got
at least the druk you need to doesn't
work as a 94 check yeah so block in the
driver's seat again play tickle time for
some tickle let's get that perpetual
tickle I think you will get tickle and
we will only have a few more games
actually four minutes left
don't take the draw here got to play
this out
this is rook da yeah no you won't like
okay okay well go succeeded that Danny
he's no longer he's no longer in the
record books as as the most brutalized
victim of Magnus Carlsen but but he is
officially of course out of the match as
we go over to the scoreboard and remind
everybody there was only four minutes
remaining in the in the total game clock
and then we will be switching to one
final chess960 game we'll talk to the
players will ask Magnus Carlsen how he
makes chess look so easy check in on his
his music playlists of choice maybe Eric
you know once again try to uh try to
pawn off some swag Magnus I don't know
if Magnus hasn't committed to the gnomes
this year Eric maybe you can poach him
for the chest broad team huh I would
love to I I was even speak I was even
speaking to two players in wild man and
it would be a dream to recruit Magnus
but I think he's pretty
thank you very much trionic right he
liked you he likes to he likes to defend
Norway and always home turf they needed
it he played a lot of matches they would
be aren't that many chess players in the
country that are able to make every
match he played he played so many
matches for them last there would be
he's irreplaceable yep well it looks
like you have swindled his way to maybe
maybe some positive tactics here against
Hussein off with this move Knight to d5
everybody obviously the rook is hanging
and and then c3 Falls
huh excuse me just had a yawn on chest
TV I mean that's not good that means
this is a yawn ER or a lapper you should
be four here okay taking back
well now okay this is opposite color
oops
yeah although okay Bishop f6 yeah you
guys say obstacle Bishop but probably
slightly better from you saying off with
this bishop
although okay wait he's down a pawn I
forgot to take a head count so hard to
say that black is is worse if he's down
a pawn but this Bishop is working here
challenges the B file you might even
take that we're playing five and his
King his King is gonna shuffle either
the d7 and c6 king of a king yet King
b76
yeah he's not where he's gonna go this
way the rook on c3 he's never really
going to get a open file g5 is a nice
trick coming cuz after takes King g6 why
does yeah yeah then you'll have to go f4
and some things that we done is we just
talked about king g6 everybody in the
pawn can't take so oh okay but you're
right black got out of that without
without really any problems it seemed
that was impressive so megawatts the
playoff for and fix those pawns on G 2
and F 3 and come up with some ideas f4
I'm expecting maybe Oh firstly wants to
stop the King from going to d4 so now
maybe Brooke you won uh-huh let me bring
the King to g3 if possible I play F for
me
Freddie is coming freddie is coming King
D for no k1 anyone yeah okay repeat one
first now Bishop c3 you can't play rook
e1 that was the only issue with this
yeah maybe Magna should have played okay
one there now he's gone into a bit of a
think he's only got a minute to convert
on this otherwise we're headed into
chess960 and no more one-minute games
asking the pawn to be pushed to a 7
because I'll do that and I'll put my
bishop on d4 I will push that Ponte 7
mega smite comes Bishop b4
a6 Bishop d4 he's 7 please play a 6 and
then oh I'm surprised by that
- is counting on e5 being some
counterplay but yeah these games could
go both ways
well officially I think we can let the
players know that this will be their
last
1 minute game heading into chess960
after this one of the first times I've
seen the bull pour should be the best
for the player losing usually the it
gets even worse so they start off strong
well we have chess960 then we have
interviews always nice to hear magnus
carlsen give his thoughts on the match
although today I'm sure that it was um
no I mean but white is playing for two
results here Danny yep he was down to
three seconds before 2:30 announced 3
seconds to 5 now he stole it so maybe
Rick uh-huh then Rick c7 I wanna bring
my King to be four I want to play King
Kings you - King bee - looking it before
if he can do that then there will indeed
be winning chances but Magnus has
smartly prevented that came from
improving his position right now you can
do it king c2 first ah da pawn can't
take it why couldn't he take the a pawn
he I'm not sure maybe was just a
practical choice he wasn't sure if there
was a tactic there but he knew the king
would be safe on a light square you know
you won't blunder owner lights right way
though that polygon output is good ears
got sometimes rook me to repeat to cut
that King off work could be to Bishop D
for Bishop D for the king is [ __ ] out of
this is bad this is oh and he's got rook
to be a coming I think who's gonna get
this one Oh roof b6 was over there as
well mm-hmm okay you saying off manages
to take the last classical bullet game
so impressive actually
he's gonna give check on b8 and take c4
and and as you said yourself you have an
Uncle Bob Bob is your uncle and
and Bob's your uncle well you say enough
pulls himself together there gets a
couple good winds down the stretch and
and now they have just 960 before they
join us and and then we will see
everybody tomorrow for the Ben Feingold
and Simon Williams match so if you doing
the commentary for that one daddy
I'll be I'm gonna let them do their own
trash-talking commentary I'm kind of
there as like a referee right like a you
know like a moderator and to kind of
keep them away from going down the rated
X path right so they got though they got
the parental advisory path already but
I'm gonna keep them from going down the
rated X path I like to think so and if
they get boring then I'll just instigate
some stuff and make up things that
they've said about each other I want to
see some crooked refereeing yeah yeah I
mean depends on how much depends on yeah
always the price always a price but okay
well you got we got chess960 here
another one I mean I gotta be honest
these chess960 positions here have been
rather chessy mm-hmm oh there goes the
chassis that is game over you win the
Queen your queen gets trapped after but
you give the Queen back to the roof and
you exchange
unfortunately that is kind of the story
of the day forged ear and we will be
bringing him on now and then then the
show will be over so the match the match
is over Magnus Carlsen is won by a final
score of 20 and a half 20 and a half to
five and a half and and and we will have
we will have them here shortly
they are looks like looks like they are
back and let's ooh they were back and
then they're gone they were back and
then they're gone
there he comes there he is
and let me let me let me get things set
up and be the first so can you guys I'm
gonna unmute you guys Magnus and Qadir
can you hear us yes thank you Magnus are
you there that's your Magnus can hear us
yet I will I will let him know well good
dear let me be the first to congratulate
you again on qualifying to be in the
event we know this was a tough ooh
and we've lost his camera again but I
think he can hear us
good dear if you can hear us your
cameras off again there we go I don't
know what's going on with that you know
this was obviously a tough matchup you
knew it coming in you're playing the
strongest player on the planet and and
he certainly played like it today what
were your thoughts as things kind of
started to get away from you and you
realize Magnus was really in top form
yeah what was playing really well
because almost all in games I lost to
him sometimes okay I miss at some points
I think about about okay one kinks one I
didn't play my take for and the nicest
it was simply win for me and after and
else I had one game with extra exchange
I think it was winning position and also
in first game I was very disappointed
because okay I had extra home in our
side Bishop's position and i blundered
but of course I know that everybody
knows that Max is very big favourite to
win all tournaments so of course for me
it was good exciting experience to play
risk in this match the the style your
style seem to be you know you you kept
pretty consistent to your opening
repertoire you seem to want to get in
positions where you could have like a
nice you know I don't know I don't know
the positional strategy is the right way
but yeah nice maneuvering kind of game
and but it seemed like Magnus obviously
we know Magnus is you know probably the
best player in the world with that
style did you just feel like you didn't
quite get sharp enough positions maybe
create enough opportunities for him to
make any blunder I suppose game I took
long one style to play some long games
and then I realize that they have to
play tactical chess and I start to
sacrifice everything and it was much
better because sometimes it was like it
and I had some some good games so I
think from first game I had to play very
aggressive and don't care about pieces
just play on and play tactically so I
think because he positional just an
in-game monks restaurant you just seen
he wants some really fantastic and games
I mean in this game it's really
difficult but he he won and he has
verified technique so it's very
difficult Magnus can you hear us now
uh-huh so how do you make chess look so
easy I don't know I don't think I did I
think you do well you played you played
very well today we it was it was a joy a
joy for us to watch congratulations
moving on where do you feel then if you
if you don't think you did where do you
where do you think you had struggles
today to be honest I think I I didn't
think I played well at any point today
so now I have to do better
nice done well in the end games that you
got against Kadir one of the consistent
things was you were up on time and do
you feel like that was a big practical
advantage maybe you even if you weren't
thrilled with your play you had more
time and some of those tricky rook
endings you managed to get a lot of full
points in positions that we thought
might end up being half points yeah for
sure
it's it's important to play faster and
blitz but yeah that's was so you played
faster this for sure well give us give
us an idea of what was going on in your
in your headphones though what was your
music today last time it was Taylor
Swift what were you jamming oh no no I
didn't have any music no music okay what
about the snacks
over your favorite snacks you had
spaghetti going yeah it was actually
some noodles those were delicious asking
questions that are fun for the fans but
Eric what are the questions can we can
we grill these guys about well one of
the questions I had for Kadir was he
seemed that some yeah you seem to have
some time trouble issues how was it when
you're trying to adjust or did you
realize that when did you realize you
were playing it too slowly because there
were there were some positions where you
ended up actually flagging I don't know
if it was a computer thing but it was it
seemed to be angry because you know last
time I played blitz maybe one year ago
something and I don't play too much and
of course it was very difficult to play
against mugs only after some games I
started to play better and better
Magnus your bullet rating went from 3200
to 2800 I know I know you're upset about
I just want to give you a chance to
express how you feel about that I know
they don't care about that I just have
to yeah well obviously obviously I'm
kidding but you yeah you uh you you did
what you did well and I guess most the
portions too despite your feelings
obviously there were a few blunders here
and there but as you look ahead into the
next matchup you're taking on Wesley so
in round 2 tentatively planned right now
for sometime in the end of November how
do you how do you think you match up
with Wesley in this format I think I
have the chance to do well I just have
to play play better than I did today
yeah I just think today and you know in
a number of games I was lucky not to
to get less points and I did so again I
just have to do a lot better and
obviously especially in the boat I
thought in the bullet I you started to
play a lot more confidently and quickly
and it threw me off a bit
yeah the positions got a lot more
tactical there in the bullet portion and
we saw we saw some more blunders but
when you look ahead to someone like
Wesley are you are you is there any
preparation that goes into that
obviously we know you guys play each
other a lot and we know that over the
board tournaments longer time controls
there's certainly more prep but do you
have any thoughts about do you put
thought into how to match up with
someone stylistically in a blitz format
it may be a different way than you would
in a classical format hmm maybe a little
bit but I think not not too much
people's strengths in blitz are usually
about the same as they are in rapid and
classical so I think it's not too
different well sorry about your cough
good year and I'm sorry that today maybe
didn't go the way you would plan
although as you said I know you told me
before that before the match today that
you knew you were in for it obviously
taking on the world champion you know
congratulations on on being here being
in the event you qualified to play
Magnus in those tournaments which was
not an easy field to make it through so
we hope to see you trying to qualify
next year Magnus I don't really know
what else to say besides good luck in
the in the next round against Wesley so
and thank you both for for some
entertaining days of chess we were we
were highly viewed on Twitch and a lot
of people had a lot of fun today so Erik
unless you have any other words I think
we can let these guys go and have their
evening for sure all right
Magnus let nice sweatshirt we appreciate
the swag when we were hoping you were
gonna wear Geoff's bra sweatshirt today
but we understand you don't have one of
those yet own first and that's
unfortunate thank you everybody for for
watching and hopefully there will be
some very good messages to come thanks
Magnus thanks good ear have a good night
guys
you guys alright Eric well we're gonna
let our players go and you know I will
well we'll just chat quickly here so
Magnus saying he didn't think he played
that well today I don't really know that
that's fair but Magnus um maybe trying
to be trying to be self-reflective when
when he knows that you this was a pretty
one-sided I mean it's also what makes
him so good right having that attitude
and and they're definitely probably were
points that maybe beyond the surface
level where he was allowing more kind of
play than he wanted to right but yeah
it's uh I was surprised at first but you
know I can see where he's coming from
yep
well um we we still had a lot of fun
we're looking forward to the next
matches obviously everyone knows that
there's a lot more speeches coming up
we're really we're really past the the
formalities now right Eric I mean the
the matches where obviously Nakamura a
heavy favorite and one in almost the
same the same disparity in points
against his opponent Sergei Grigoryants
today Magnus putting on a show I think
we're away from the lopsided victories
now and I think it's pretty safe to say
that all the matches from here on out
are gonna be super close yeah I know I
don't know who to pick in the in three
of the matchups knock knock Americans
Caruana
Nepal Miyagi car yakin and VL agree
shook I think I think recent trends I
think should favor maybe Magnus / Wesley
Wesley hasn't had a great wall it hasn't
been this past year he's taking a few
more losses and and if Magnus continues
is upward momentum that he has going for
him right now
then and now I would say he's the
biggest favorite in the second round
yep well Eric thanks for flying
alongside here this was a lot of fun I
think I think we got some good moments
here despite despite one way the one
one-sided victory obviously we'll be
doing this again really soon and I'm
gonna take the fans home here with a one
less look into our sponsor masterclass
and their work with Gary Kasparov
obviously big deal coming your way still
not available to get yet but you can't
pre subscribe you can pre enroll if you
go to masterclass comm slash chess
pretty sure there's a masterclass comm
slash Kasparov and pretty much anything
else you could think of so consider
doing that especially if you're a
tournament player around the 1300 to
1500 level this stuff is exactly what
you need to be local so Eric thanks man
and I'm gonna play this trailer one more
time and you and I will see each other
in a future match Danny it was a lot of
fun but I'll see ya
you
check chess is a game of unlimited
beauty but it's not just check stand
attacks you have to be creative
I'm here to share with you my knowledge
on the game of chess but I'm trying to
come up with the comprehensive picture
that will be helpful for you to become a
better chess player and even a better
decision made let's cover King t5 King
c2 King f6 can be sneaking g17c 14 to 16
b5 King Cecil King lacings boom white
lost yes
Quinn takes the knight f5 and it's
double attack skew and attraction and
its mate but an amazing mate how can we
prevent this rope from stopping our corn
let's pause stop the video and see you
have time to find this winning
combination did you see that it's the
officials whether you have not support
no I never say that that's that's
interesting so you attack my bishop then
you protect your bishop right so let's
go back and see whether we can improve
and what's the next logical rules it's
about coming up with new ideas
challenging your own excellence find
your mistakes next time you have better
I've been thinking about a few ideas
that I never used one I want to show
it's another sacrifice that like
sacrifices and it's one of my favorite
openings so just let's have a look
can waste time time is precious
if you don't feel that the game can
leash your creative potential then you
already will lose your son it's not
about winning or losing and of course at
the end of the day it's about winning
coach I'm Gary Kasparov and this is my
master class